peu
[Musique]
m
photo en haut en bas bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui regardent nadir tous les
samedis soirs avec nous le bagagiste de
roissy et nationair gens dorment chance
l'interdît 20 go
julie andrieu
christophe alévêque
le fondateur de reporters sans
frontières
moustiques et benoît delépine lionel
richie jérôme savary et notre gamme
light est consacré ce soir aux soldes
mais la mission
[Applaudissements]
m
avant de recevoir nos premiers invités
je vous propose de regarder les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean yves
noël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après neuf mois de cauchemar aux états
unis vous êtes rentré en france michael
le 21 décembre dernier qui vous a sorti
de là ce sont mes avocats
ouais monsieur le président la
république votre aide et l'aide de tous
les français aussi
ben voilà on applaudit ça va pas mal
j'ai un vidéo sampler si des fois
quelque chose qui vous plaît pas voilà
ce que je passerai c'est lamentable
c'est vraiment la mode donc ça vous
évitera de répéter comme ça plusieurs
fois pendant l'émission joffrin
technique je pense qu'il faut le passer
si vous avez voilà alors bien dit si
vous êtes considéré comme le séducteur
du cinéma français l'homme dont rêve
tout est déjà passé tout de suite le
match
allez-y à part vous pierre qui peut
jouer en attendant godot de beckett et
joyeuses pâques de poiret il y en a il y
en a mais n'ont pas déçu mais s'il y en
a j'ai un truc pour ce que je suis en
train de faire du chemin
j'ai loupé un truc r il s'en servira
plus que moi alors à part vous c'est con
hein
à part vous qui a eu le privilège d'être
second rôle derrière bernard tapie
voulez-vous on me repasser oui
la question de lionel jospin pierre
arditi oui si ces représentations sont
un échec
est-ce que vous assumerait pleinement la
responsabilité de cet échec
est-ce que vous en tirez les conclusions
en vous retirant de la vie théâtrale
après le 18 janvier voulez vous me
passez limité pour le petit je savais
que ça servirait vous êtes là vous allez
me faire par exemple un beau c'est
lamentable comme ça je l'aurais en stack
c'est lamentable mais c'est lamentable
esprit me faire un ses remarquables ça
j'aurai les deux c'est remarquable année
parce que vous avez pas bien non plus
toutes les semaines
produire ces remarques à bout c'est
lamentable voilà c'est ça comme ça où je
peux je fais potiche même quand je suis
pas lassé non merci
ils ont been migé le monde
ai-je qui est toujours lochies projet
toujours
enfin michel toujours et où l'on rigole
il n'a jamais dit qu'elle était colle à
la peau
la personne qui est en charge des
destinées de mon pays je préfère le
savoir sensible à ce genre de choses aux
plaisirs de la vie en tout cas plutôt
que le contraire
ce que vous êtes en train de dire là
c'est qu'il faudrait mieux que george
bush se fasse tailler des pipes par
monica médina
moi quand je parle de femmes dans
l'entourage du président mitterrand je
peux pas vous affirmer qu'elles ont
toutes été ses maîtresses oui bah parce
que forcément mon rôle à un moment
s'arrêter et la porte se fermait pas ce
qui se passait là bas nous on a des
images quand même
c'est consternant a vraiment à ça tu vas
me le faire ça
c'est consternant pour vous dites vous
la lutte pour l'égalité s'est mué en un
combat pour la différence hommes femmes
la preuve dites vous la parité qu'on
inscrit dans la constitution
la parité si vous voulez on non non non
attendez attendez ne me répondait pas
[Musique]
voici javel alonso
ce qui vous énerve c'est que cette
communauté la communauté gay revendique
à la fois le droit à l'indifférence et
le droit à la différence
voici jean luc romero on parle
effectivement de communautés musulmanes
de communautés juives et c'est un peuple
qui a beaucoup souffert de sa maison
natale
ouais si gilles william goldnadel
alors à quand votre livre vous en prenez
également aux petits juges devenu
synonyme de redresseur de sport ces
derniers instants et avide de toujours
plus de pureté ne me répondez pas car
voici un mois
[Musique]
là si le juge eric halphen il les a tous
d'alain minc alors je vous laisse
conclure ce fameux la mousserie fortes
averses et c'est pas fini
mes passages à tabac etc
l'iphone sauf que nathan va falloir
sortir et s'affirma dans la poche diriez
quoi sur les femmes si vous étiez un mec
qu'elles sont extraordinaires ah bon
ouais vous n'êtes pas encore un mec
alors c'est la guerre
ses parents lui
ça me coûte bonne vous seriez be ou
hétéro bi bi un garçon bien la danse
elle coulait là j'ai un petit passage à
vide mais si jean jean
[Musique]
comme ça
voilà changement de tri page reçoit
maintenant ça m'ira hichem et abderrazak
besseghir
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les trois donc ça
m'ira vous préparer le concours de
professeur des écoles après avoir fait
une licence d'anglais
hichem vous êtes étudiant en maîtrise
d'administration économique et sociale
et vous abderrazak vous êtes bagagistes
à roissy après un bac 2 commerce et un
bts voilà nous trois on se connaît on
s'est vus la semaine dernière je lui
avais demandé la semaine dernière à
samira à guichets mme de venir parce
qu'on était persuadé évidemment de
l'innocence de abderrazak besseghir et
puis ensuite il a été libéré le vendredi
donc voila et vous êtes là ce soir avec
avec vous abderrazak et on est très
heureux que vous soyez là
[Applaudissements]
désir
tout ce que vous appelez la patronne un
problème donc abdou vous avez été
interpellé le 28 décembre dernier puis
mis en examen par le juge t-il le 1er
janvier pour association de malfaiteurs
en relation avec une entreprise
terroriste
avant d'être libéré dix jours plus tard
dix jours durant lesquels vous n'avez
cessé de proclamer votre innocence au
sujet des armes trouvées dans le coffre
de votre 206 noir
alors aujourd'hui bon ben ça fait une
semaine que vous êtes libéré est ce que
vous avez retrouvé le calme après cette
incroyable aventure
le calme pas encore on est passé d'un
extrême à un autre on va dire de la
solitude a fait des grands jours vous
êtes fatigués là un peu non je suis
insomniaque en soient avisés du mal à
dormir
oui et en prison vous dormiez non ils
vous donnent pas détruit pour dormir
si j'en avais mais apparemment mon corps
et je sais pas ouais trop énervé ouais
énervé alors on va pas vous demander
abdou dirt déballer tout le dossier ce
soir ici depuis le suicide de louisa et
c'est parce que vous êtes fatigués
effectivement vous êtes épuisé
il faut vous reposez vous allez mettre
tout cela au clair le fait de faire un
témoignage
et quand vous leur ai écrit ce
témoignage vous viendra en parler ici et
voilà mais sans à vous remercier déjà
parce que je sais que vous avez reçues
mon frère et ma soeur et
je tenais à signaler qu'il ya des
grosses institutions qui négligent la
présomption d'innocence et des gens qui
sont humainement ont du coeur tout
simplement les antiennes compte et ça
c'est important
heureusement qu'il ya encore des gens
comme vous merci rené de desservir la
télévision dans ce genre de cas voilà
comment va me dit ça va bien a gelé au
téléphone tout à l'heure ça ouais le 14
à brive en avoir 15
il n'a jamais eu le loisir d'aller vite
et avec vous l'appartement où vous
deviez visiter le avant noël quoi non
non vous allez le voir cet appartement
maintenant pas je me pose encore la
question je serais vraiment dans la
région ouais ouais carrément assez au
point vous pensez vous en allez tout à
l'origine c'était quelqu'un d'assez
discret ouais aujourd'hui une star parce
que j'y mets alors ouais alors ce qui
est assez tragique dans votre affaire
abdou c'est que vous vous voulez
vraiment vous intégrez c'est à dire que
vous avez fait des études vous avez
trouvé un boulot un petit peu d'ailleurs
comme hicham est et samira voulez
vraiment vous intégrer et vivre comme un
français normal d'origine arabe mais un
français musulman oui d'accord
croyant mais pas fervent pas papa
islamistes assez clair et alors
vous voulez être un citoyen français et
vous tombez sur des flics qui vous
traite de sale [ __ ] et qui vous disent
ta gueule [ __ ]
ça fait quoi ça est-ce que d'un coup
c'est pas le monde qui vous tombe sur la
tête
c'est vrai que j'avais affaire à des
gens qui étaient je pense qu'il manquait
un peu de jugeote
ouais ok pour une gt correspondait au
profil type quoi on nous a jugés sous
forme a jugé simplement sur un délit de
sale gueule
malheureusement il y avait quelque chose
qui a éclaté au grand jour que je pense
que je croyais déjà qui existaient déjà
et là je pense que peut-être que
justement avec la tournure de l'histoire
ça donnera peut-être ça poussera
peut-être les gens à réfléchir un peu
plus j'espère j'espère que ça servira de
leçon et que les innocents qui n'a
encore aujourd'hui en prison qui
pourrissent pour rien c'est dommage
parce que malheureusement que j'avais ma
famille mes amis et puis oui du monde
qui se bouge est derrière ce mot mais
peut-être qu'ils y sont parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de famille et pas d'amis
exact alors vous avez été abdou giflé
frappé insulté humilié pour vous faire
avouer
vous avez jamais avoué évidemment
puisque rien avoué est au bout de huit
jours vous n'aviez toujours pas avouer
malgré malgré les sévices dont vous avez
été victime apparemment je les trouve
les mêmes les avait du mal à cerner son
caractère le personnage mais j'avais
rien à cacher donc depuis la première
seconde où j'ai été interpelé je leur ai
dit tout de suite ce qu'il en était donc
c'est un complot et que ouais j'essaye
même d aiguiser dans leur enquête
non mais vraiment je passais pour être
honnête honnête ça fait ça fait
maintenant chacun avait des gens qui
réfléchissent pas beaucoup qui juge les
gens par rapport à l'appartenance
religieuse leur apportant dans ce
malheureux d'en arriver là pourquoi ils
ont mis huit jours à interroger vos
collègues de travail
aucune idée alors que
alors que tout de suite je leur ai dit
qu au moment où la personne soit disant
qu'on avait vu j'étais déjà dans
l'enceinte mais c'est parce qu'on était
jugé pour ce correspondait au profil
type
ouais apparemment pour l'interrogatoire
c'était surréaliste parce qu'il vous
parlez tnt et vous savez même pas ce que
c'était vous leur disiez la tnt ça un
petit magasin d'électronique je pensais
que c'est un point de vue ou alors si
une société de transport convoi
l'autoroute sur le terrain quand on
passe à aulnay savais même pas ce que
c'était quoi je parle a dit que j'avais
même pas une batte de baseball dans la
voiture a donc ré je sais pas oui contre
des armes des explosifs dans la voiture
je tombais sur le cucquois jeu comment
ça s'est passé avec les justes il en a
fait un monologue chacun son côté pas de
conversation pas de communication à la
salle et moi partir du moment où j'étais
omagad aviv a commencé donc on va jouer
cartes sur table tout de suite qu'on
entende parler j'ai vu que j'avais jalal
en prison directement mais j'étais même
pressé d'y aller oui c'est malheureux à
dire mais j'étais pressé dans la prison
a quitté la garde à vue alors samira
hill chem quand on vous lisez le journal
le parisien le 31 décembre et que vous
lisez ce titre à quel usage le bagagiste
de roissy
destiné t-il l'arsenal et la bombe
retrouvée dans sa voiture
est-ce que là en voyant ça dans le
journal c'est tellement affirmatif
est ce que vous dites pas peut-être que
mon frère a fait une connerie moi j'ai
lu des articles de journaux mais la
presse a essayé de nous faire croire des
choses moi je savais qu'à souhaiter
qu'elles étaient fausses mais mon frère
je le connais depuis 21 ans
on peut pas du jour au lendemain à me
dire non tu connais pas cette personne
c'est pour moi c'était absolument
impossible on a essayé de faire passer
pour ce qu'il n'est pas tout simplement
alors ce journal le parisien a pris
position assez vite puisque ensuite on a
eu comme titre bagagiste de roissy 2
points
la piste terroriste confirmait donc là
d'un seul coup vous étiez carrément vous
étiez devenu ben laden
1 ensuite le portable du bagagiste parle
c'est marrant ça ouais
ce qu'ils ont trouvé qu'ils avaient le
niveau de son délégué syndical qui
lui-même avait le numéro d'une personne
qui a été entendue
seulement rien du tout ni qui avait été
au moment du match france algérie au
stade de france
mais vous vous aviez pas téléphoné à
harry de tous niveaux et de téléphoner à
quelqu'un qui lui avait téléphoné à rick
tenu à ce coup de fil à de facilement
trois mois avant way from an avant
l'arrestation tous les trois là vous
êtes déçu par votre pays ou non quand
même un peu
abdou moi je sais pas comment vous
répondre à cette question parce que
c'est j'ai vécu ça extérieurement avant
des histoires qu'on voyait à travers les
médias après je les ai vécus
personnellement je pense qu'il faut pas
jeter l'épongé
et bien c'est bien moi qu'on me disait
on visse à travers les articles
on voit certaines injustices peuvent
être commises mais quand ça vous touche
ça ça fait mal comme on la trouve ça
fait très mal parce qu' on essaie de
construire son petit bout de chemin et
du jour au lendemain on vous met des
barrages tout simplement
alors d'où quand on vous parle du sort
que vous voudriez voir réserver à votre
belle famille qui responsable maintenant
on le sait de la machination
vous répondez je ne vais pas envoyer de
pauvres gens en prison
au fond du trou d'où je viens je les ai
oublié qu'il m'oublie
vous pratiquez le pardon des offenses
j'ai pas compris
oui c'est une phase de kato en même
temps vous leur avez pardonné
non je leur pardonne pas c'est parce
qu'on m'a quand même fait beaucoup de
mal on a fait du mal à un enfant de 14
mois
je sais pas humainement ce n'est pas
possible et j'ai pas de sentiments
vis-à-vis de donc pas même un sentiment
de haine ou de mépris ou d'égout je
pense que c'est déjà accordé de
l'importance à une personne donc
sont aux mains de la justice mais c'est
parfois l'un juste
j'espère que cette fois elle va être
juste qu'elle a les cartes en main oui
est-ce que vous pardonner aux
journalistes et aux flics
non non parce que c'est quand tout de
suite la première seconde clamer votre
innocence et qu'on vous donne pas un
minimum de crédibilité
un peu l'impression que vous n'êtes plus
rien qu'au ouais j'sais pas eu tant
attendu j'ai pas été écoutés donc après
on se rattrape après pas sur la presse
ou c'est dommage vous n'avez pas été
considéré comme un citoyen non non non
c'était plus ces puces algérien que
français
ouais pendant quinze jours ouais quelle
morale vous retirer de cette histoire
hichem bas je pense que ça va être assez
difficile à oublier tout ça ouais et qu'
on est on est dans le pays on va se
battre pour prouver qu'on que le pays
nous appartient aussi
sept français je suis français quelle
morale vous retirer de cette affaire
abdou bâ que déjà la vie à chara fauvin
vraiment profiter de ces petits moments
moi je regrette un petit moment que
j'avais pas passer la nuit la veille
avec mon enfant donc
soit à tout le monde du bonheur et que
profiter des moindres petits moments de
leur vie et que peut-être que cette
histoire qui m'arrivait même si moi j'en
ai su refaire j'espère que ça évitera se
fait sur le dos de personnes quoi
inutilement samira moi c'est pareil je
pourrais pas oublier ça c'est clair mais
maintenant une morale c'est que l'on
nous montre que finalement on est petit
coin n'a pas n'a pas de pouvoir
finalement dans une démocratie c'est
assez bizarre
merci à tous les trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
non
m
voici un monsieur bergues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nationaux madame messieurs comment ça
va ça vient
comment vas tu iras tu iras tu là on se
doit elle est un peu malade la nuit et
fièvre a besoin de gâcher la soirée sa
page nous une joie qu'on se voit un peu
plus d'un an maintenant tu iras oui très
ce mois bah oui oui oui mesdames
messieurs et wii et wii et maman vous en
rêviez depuis longtemps mais merci à
tous mais bon pas trop mal mais bon je
dors la vie commence c'est ça c'est le
plus important que je fais dans ma vie
on s'en souvient la nuit tôt à faire
devant un problème et m'a quand même
alors c'est quand vous singer l'odeur
l'odeur non quand il m'a rencontrée ma
rencontre un homme elle voit tout de
suite le père potentiel c'est à dire que
tout de suite elle se dit est-ce que ça
pourrait être le père de mes enfants et
ça c'est tout le monde ne peut pas
rentrer dans ces problèmes mais je crois
avec moi mon âge
oui c'est vrai je suis bon coup de feu
les sexes de la sex bomb mais c'est vrai
que si vous voulez vous asseoir et quant
à quelqu'un vraiment aujourd'hui le
pensait pour la future ses vrais cheveux
bien famille elle l aime avoir le
sentiment d'appartenir à quelqu'un oui
ça c'est bon pour une suédoise a une
mentalité d'italiennes moi je pense que
les sujets je pensais que les suédois
ces défis libérer ou non ses destroyers
la réputation de ce doigt ça c'est
bergman c'est donc maintenant c'est la
faute à vermelles la faute alors voilà
donc je dis à nos amis téléspectateurs
emma sjöberg cherche un papa pour ses
enfants
ce qu'est match ouvert donc on n'en a
pas à l'époque à lui comment j'étais
coincé 1
on n'était pas tout à fait pareil ni
vous ni moi c'est bien marché a trouvé
l'homme et bella voilà alors l'heureux
papa de tirah s'appelle hans en ville
count betrand à l'arrêt pourquoi lui
oui pourquoi pas et les amours et les
gentils il est le meilleur papa d'et la
main tout le monde d'accord mais comme
marie comment il est on n'a pas encore
mariés vous avez bien que pour faire un
enfant avait bien dû quand même à
merveille les regards devraient se
tasser petit benjamin fond d'amour oui
elle est très positive l enam of ray un
sénat mourrons tous meilleurs grands
l'amour de ma vie et ma qu'est ce qu'il
a de plus que les autres hans pourquoi
lui fait pas comme ça que je l'imaginais
à pourquoi lui pourquoi lui c'est quoi
lui mort et de vue humain you malabry
d'humour mais j'ai beaucoup d'humour
regarde ce que je fais regarde wacip
est ce que ça marche non sérieusement il
m'a il paraît qu'avec ans sexuellement
c'est fabuleux
mais ça c'est très très privé je crois
je restais ça avec moi mais je suis très
content nos mines un nom et ma psy
vraiment si vraiment ça se passait mal
entre ses mains
si je posais des questions voilà on
regarde regarde ce que tu peux faire ok
au yoyo et pourquoi pas ce que je vais
demander pourquoi son mari était son
mari qu'est-ce qu'il avait plus que les
autres non mais moi je crois c'est parce
que vous êtes très jaloux c'est un peu
c'est pas ça la bourse est le meilleur
pour le visage et tout bon
quel bonheur vient enfin le problème
alors sérieusement maintenant le
problème c'est quand il vit en suède il
est critique de cinéma
il est critique de cinéma sur une chaîne
suédoise qui s'appelle tv4 ouais
et qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de taxi 1
il n'a pas fait leurs adieux parce que
c'est pas sorti au cinéma en semaine je
suis très content mais est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu le faire pas sorti mais
pour les frapper le critique mais qu'est
ce qu'il a pensé des taxis 1 et 2
puisque là on est au trois sérieusement
oui ça c'est pas vraiment le film que
lui non ah oui il a un peu intellectuel
il a rien dire à moi parce que ça va ce
problème à la maison ça va c'est le
monde et national elle est formidable
vous avez ça fait ça fait deux ans que
je dis à catherine barba mais quand est
ce qu elle revint alors qui donc
personne a vu le signe puisque besson
n'a pas voulu le montrer c'est vous qui
allez le raconter donc ça s'appelle taxi
3 s'est produit évidemment par besson
que vous avez connu d'ailleurs lors du
casting du cinquième élément de s'en
voulait même pas rappelé non
heureusement qui s'est souvenu pour taxi
s'est réalisée par gérard caustique avec
frédéric diefenthal samy naceri marion
cotillard bernard farcy
et vous dans le rôle de pétra toi c'est
quoi l'histoire le pitch moi ça se passe
à marseille c'est quoi c'est à marseille
mais c'est aussi aux tigres
cette fois la neige n'y pas beaucoup de
films
non parce que ça va sortir neuf en être
à vous raconter ses pannes non c'est
mieux pour les gens pouvoir c'est
beaucoup mieux d'argent comme ça magnéto
serge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention
[Musique]
c'est fini les vacances de noël
kim est engagée parce que je pensais
qu'on se sentait bien la gueule
[Musique]
alors oui c'est pour un rendez vous
concertation réflexion action
[Musique]
il était de se faire remarquer comme ça
en l'air décontracté il puisse passera
bien
maintenant là ça serait bien qu'un
miracle
ça maintient
[Musique]
déployez vos
il n'y a pas de doute c'est noël
c'est le sport pro noah
[Musique]
une autre taxi problème monsieur chat
sort le 29 janvier
tout le monde m'en parler
casser la bande originale du film
ça s'appelle qu'est ce que tu fous cette
nuit sébastien fraysse et la bande
originale de taxi 3 il ya au 613 il ya
aussi arsenic
il ya aussi corneille si doc gynéco et
oxmo voilà c'est bien vous avez bien la
musique voix oui je connais pas très
bien le musique en français le rap mais
bon je viens vous avez connu beaucoup de
musiciens des chrétiens notamment ulf
wilex way
les icebergs
il est toujours très gentil vous le
voyez toujours eu des tensions
oui à web rien on se dit mais qu'est ce
qui dit quand vous voyez ulf bonjour
comme tout le monde joue ça va oui c'est
très calme très bien ça se passe très
bien c'est toi c'est que l'italie se
serait pas comme ça c'est bien alors on
parlait du groupe est effectivement en
parler du groupe ace of bays donc il ya
un grand groupe qui a perdu cette
semaine un membre important c'est les
bee gees
ah oui ce que maurice gibb et morts et
beaucoup de gens le regrette
et alors maurice gibb il y avait un truc
il énervait beaucoup c'est qu'on se
souvienne les bee gees uniquement à
travers ce théine live parce qu'il
disait j'ai écrit plein de trucs dans ma
vie c'est écrit que c'est une espèce de
daube disco c'est vrai dix ans avant
saturday night fever les bee gees ont
fait des chansons merveilleuses à la fin
des années 60
didier
[Musique]
et
ben
on
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ah oui
mais les guillaume de la fcx au la règle
et
nous aurons accès
parce que
[Musique]
que sa taille
d
[Musique]
voilà les bee gees et et olivier parce
que les bee gees s'est pas seulement ses
murailles voilà alors ça c'est la
musique de l'époque où j'étais
adolescent et vous quand vous étiez
adolescent on vous appelez le troll ah
oui le treuil vous étiez grand maigre
oui avec le jeu c'est pas le grand boum
le dans cet appareil dentaire aussi
voilà ces trolls voilà jusqu'au jour où
à yun que ping ping
yann shopping shopping j'arriverai je
suis sûr que au bout de quelques années
dans une boîte de nuit a été sélectionné
pour un concours pour une crème solaire
et après c'est devenu un succès
planétaire marché au comptant pour le
prêt des salaires ouais
et j'aimerais vous avez été la belle
suédoise l'instar de paris à milan à new
york à miami etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi comme vous jouez dans taxi un taxi
de taxi 3 et bientôt taxi 4
on va faire l'interview de taxi oui
venez vous asseoir la derrière moi donc
interdit aux taxis des masques bergues
dites moi madame le ça vous dérange que
j'écoute les grosses têtes là ça va ça
vous plaît les grosses têtes ça va c'est
pas tenable
je connais pas très bien
bah vous n'êtes pas français c'est pour
ça ça c'est ça fait pas marrer les
suédois n'ont cessé ces noyades avec
harry dites moi vous avez habitué à
préférer la rive droite rive gauche sait
pas quand vous voulez mais moi c'est
vous qui décidez à moi je conduis beau
pays hockey pouvait passer par c'est pas
grave par où je vais d'accord dites moi
c'est pas beaucoup avaient déjà joué
dans taxi l'un oui oui c'est vrai il est
sympa ça me diefenthal le des sondés
sont très sympas ça mais la série demi
finale c'est un bon accord très gentille
et besson il paye bien pas terrible
ah bon
et sinon vous avez fait de timbo n'ont
pas pris non non non le site de pipe du
temps ce toit mais non c'est vrai que
c'est laetitia casta qui vous a donné
l'idée d'être comédienne ah non non
c'est moi qui a aidé l aller tout seul
en lice sinon quand vous étiez même qu'à
vous marchiez plus vite ou moins vite
que claudia schiffer beaucoup plus vite
et mieux
une petite gamme vous prenez souvent le
pepsi
non c'est trop cher je préfère le métro
avec marc hé ouais donc c'est juste la
troisième fois que le taxi c'est ça
alors elle dit moi vous pensez que j'ai
une gueule à faire du ciné - non pas du
tout
aie aie tous les films que vous faites
avec mcv sont là vous devez reconnaître
de la star vous ah oui oui c'est bon
c'est que olf experts gilbert
[Applaudissements]
et ardisson vous le connaissez un nom à
oui un petit peu il sape avait rien
c'est un mec bien oui il est très bon
c'est ça a l'air d'être une tête de con
mais en fait c'est pas vrai ah non pas
du tout non non non c'est pas vrai j'ai
senti une amour avec tout le monde
vraiment grand dites moi madame vous
avez déjà fait d'amour de taxi à wii
plus et fois ça dépend des chauffeurs
vous allez jouer dans taxi 4 ses surnoms
à je ne sais pas ça bien ça c'est le
point le pouls paiement c'est mieux payé
peut-être mal géré la course est pour
moi je peux pas vous raconter cela je
vous en prie à bientôt même si bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
tél
[Musique]
et maintenant avec le temps avec le
temps va tout s'en va
voici jean d'ormesson
[Applaudissements]
jean d'ormesson
alors
[Applaudissements]
si l'on voulait pas qu'ils veulent avoir
atteint la demi non j'en ai désolé il
peut pas m'embrasser sur la bouche parce
qu'il est académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacez il avait
lui ai alors j'ai reçu un mail après
votre dernier passage dans l'émission un
mail d'arnaud salomon qui a 25 ans et
qui habite à lille et qui dit juste pour
dire qu'en voyant jean d'ormesson
ça donne vraiment envie de devenir
académicien ça je sais ça charmant
voilà alors j'ai pu bien lui qui voulait
appeler adieu donc voilà en fait seul
hésité entre adieu les carottes sont
cuites il va faire est dans le sac ou et
voilà le travail et voilà le travail
c'est pas mal et finalement donc ça
s'appelle c'était bien et c'est chez
gallimard mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
voilà c'était bien alors c'est pas un
roman c'est pas des mémoires c'est pas
un essai c'est quoi un truc assez un
truc à vous auriez dû le marquer à la
place pour tresser le reste un truc
santé oms et parce que sinon je sais pas
les mémoires
non non c'est pas un effet pas ce qu'on
me dit de quoi parlez vous j'avais très
peur que vous me disiez de quoi parlez
vous dénoncez très compliqué c'est en
fait une espèce de d'état des lieux m
voilà autant dire qu'on peut dire ça
mais bon comment comment ça va voilà
comment sa valeur pendant que j'explique
comment ça va j'explique aussi aux
lecteurs comment lui va voilà à peu près
voilà alors le pitch finalement c'est
votre vie le pitch le fameux bien il
faudrait une méthode implique l académie
se voit je compte sur vous pour que le
mot pitt se rendre dans le dictionnaire
alors je n'ai pas encore fait entre à
l'académie je les fais entrer chez
gallimard et je leur ai dit je vais vous
expliquer le pitch yeux piquent et
personne chez gallimard vous savez ce
que vous voulez bien le fera pas alors
j'ai dit mais comment vous n'écoutez pas
ardisson lui en faire
[Applaudissements]
et à l'intention de ceux qui font les
études ouais je leur ai même dit par
exemple quel est le pitch de phèdre le
pitch de fait c'est une dame est
amoureuse de son beau fils
malheureusement le beau fils est victime
d'un accident de la circulation voilà
voilà le pitch c'est fait c'est quoi le
pitch de la recherche
le pitch l'ua cherche c'est un petit
gars on attend une bd de sa mère
l'asseoir dans la nuit et comme on ne
vient pas suffisamment à son gré il va
dans les bals pour se consoler voilà
voilà le pitch de la recherche alors le
pizzo votre book à 10 ans et ma vie
bilan globalement très positif est ce
que je peux apporter une toute petite
âme et molle ou ce qui est positif ce
n'est pas ma vie
c'est là aussi c'est la vie ma vie elle
aurait pu être mieux
je serai minou et je serai gide je serai
aragon je serai extrêmement satisfaits
n'étant pas ragon traitant pas
chateaubriand n'étant pas gide
je suis un peu mélancolique mais ce qui
est bien c'est la vie c'est la vie c'est
la vie
en tous les cas là ça donne l'occasion
d'être avec vous là spécialement pour
écrire ça c'était bien
c'est alors en tous les cas vous n'avez
jamais eu besoin de psy voix non
non vous avez survécu à la psychanalyse
un nouveau roman vous avez survécu à
jean paul sartre
ça c'est pas mal quand même non bah oui
il y en a qui ont laissé des plumes
alors il ya une autre façon de pitch est
votre livre j'en sais il ya deux grandes
interrogations dans la vie l'une au
début c'est que faire et l'autre c'est à
la fin qu'ai-je fait c'est une façon de
le raconter aussi
alors écoutez je vois qu'il ya ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont 20 ans et si je
vous dois quelque chose
thierry et je vous dois beaucoup c'est
que probablement vous m'avez fournit des
lecteurs plus jeune que ce que j'avais
quand j'écrivais au plaisir de dieu
j'avais sûrement les lecteurs que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui était sûrement
beaucoup plus âgés et peut-être que les
gens qui glissent mainteant sont un peu
plus jeunes grâce en partie à m
en effet c'est vrai dans ce qu'il faut
lire sans faire de fausse modestie
c'est vrai que cette émission est
beaucoup regardé par les jeunes et
qu'elle vend des livres et alors quand
j'avais maintenant vous savez eh bien je
trouvais sa tribu vraiment je trouvais
ça très dur et pourtant j'avais des
avantages énormes à 20 ans j'étais
fonctionnaire
j'étais entré à l'école normale j'étais
payé ma carrière et a été engagé au bon
en plus quand j'avais 20 ans je crois
que le taux de chômage était de 0,4 pour
cent c'est à dire que ce qu'on voulait
faire on trouve et où il ya métier vous
deviez et bien malgré ça j'ai trouvé ça
très dur d'avoir 20 ans il y avait une
phrase célèbre de dix ans vous
connaissez je me permettrai à personne
déduire que 20 ans et le plus bel âge de
la vie eh bien c'était vrai montant
alors je vous jure que je ne cherche pas
à faire de la démagogie
ouais mais je trouve que les gens qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui ont vraiment
beaucoup de courage parce qu'ils sont
très gais ça embêterait est très très
confiants et moi je trouve ça épatant
alors votre précédent livre gens simples
et voyez comme en danse et ça commençait
déjà autour du cercueil d'un d'un ami à
c'est déjà un peu vous commenté ray
d'une semaine vous savez vous savez
c'est vrai et vous savez quelque fois on
me dit alors qu'est ce que tu penses de
ton livre et je dis je ne sais pas je
n'ai encore vu personne et c'est les
gens qui lisent les livres qui
m'apprennent et kim tout à coup c'est
vrai ce livre ci tourne quand même
beaucoup autour de 2,1 alors oui elle
annonce d'année par l'annnonce de ma
mort est prématurée oui mais enfin bon
moi excusez moi je suis si vous faites
ça pour qu'on vous il reste avec nous et
non ses moi il ya en tenez regardez moi
ces vols puns et valbonne enfin le lift
précédents s'étaient déjà à
l'enterrement et je sais pas peut-être
que quelques-uns d'entre vous se
souviennent d'un livre qui s'appelait la
douane le maire et je mourrai à la
première page
alors évidemment c'est un problème qui
m'a un peu
pour conjurer le sort je suis sur moi
c'est peut-être aussi certaines vous
savez on traite ange apparaît beaucoup
comme lui fais de champion un peu benêt
du bonheur le crétin qui trouve que tout
va bien
il ya aussi sûrement une grande
mélancolie il en est dans mes livres le
public mais une mélancolie à ses gains
jeudi à tous les gens qui sont ici
profiter de jean d'ormesson pasquin a
pas beaucoup des comme ça moi j'en
profite au maximum si je pouvais l'avoir
cinq fois par an entre la salle 3 bat
d'abord merci thierry je voudrais
ajouter que profiter de moi vous n'avez
plus pour si longtemps et ensuite étiré
je vais vous demander est ce que je
pourrais avoir ici un rôle serviette
oui mes pantoufles mais attendez parce
que quand j'arrive là évidemment j'ai
l'impression le mieux chez moi j'écoute
attendant cache non que vous voulez
remplacer d'affi vous pouvez bien alors
le côté du bouquin alors il ya cette
phrase vous vous dites
la vie c'est les livres les femmes et
des bains de mer et gaston gallimard lui
disaient les bars les femmes et alors si
c'est quand même pas un jouet réponse
est patent vrai c'est pas tant les
balmer bon vous voyez ce que c'est ça
veut dire pas seulement les balles mais
bon les courses en voiture
l'italie les îles grecques
les voyages à
voilà je suis à mademoiselle et voilà
bon et puis les femmes adorent ça c'est
bien parce que on m'a souvent dit à la
télévision pas de tunnel et bien pas que
tunnel sur les femmes
on n'en parle pas pour le moment ni on
n'en parle pas alors aînés lure alors on
peut en parler vous parle évidemment des
thèmes qui sont des thèmes
or mais sonia come on come on dira
bientôt le privilège de la naissance de
sens de l'histoire parler du big bang
c'est très très riche si les thèmes
souvent abordés mais cette fois c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite mélancolie ya
quelque chose d'un petit peu comme ça
quoi la fêlure dans crystal le thème de
la naissance j'ai pensé que au fond bon
j'ai été élevé ou est-ce que j'ai été
élevé
j'ai été levée dans un château bah oui
eh ben c'est mon trotskisme à mort il ya
des gens qui ont un passé trotskiste
bombe a très très bien pourquoi les
emmerder avec ça éternellement
et ben moi non plus on va pas m'emmerder
andré était éleveur à château est tout à
fait plus trop ce qu'ils lui en reste
quelque chose du château il en reste
quelque chose d'aussi mais on essaie
d'oublier tout ça voilà le bilan ou fait
finalement de la vie d'une certaine
façon j'en sais comment s'est guère plus
en partant qu'en arrivant quoi un nom
alors si c'était à refaire
si c'était à refaire je ne leur ferai
pas un non franchement j'ai trouvé ça
épatant j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé la
vie est si bon génie ou un mauvais génie
me disais voilà tu peux recommencer je
crois quand je commencerai évidemment si
vous avez un nom comme ça
ou pas
et oui alors évidemment abordé mais
c'est vite quoi ça aurait été possible
aussi la masse est là mais c'est vite la
messe est dite alors qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez si votre vie était à refaire
imaginons vous acceptiez de la refaire
vous changeriez quoi vous feriez les
mêmes les mêmes folies des mêmes
terrains rocheux cachait peut-être de
rencontrer un peu plus tôt ça faisait
survivre à votre mort parce que vous
allez rester dans la postérité non la
postérité
oui j'ai croisé mâle alors vous savez
j'y crois plus beau ah bon je pense que
la postérité il fasse est une idée de
l'avenir
eh bien je crois que cette idée de
l'avenir appartient au passé
vous savez pourquoi un peu à cause de
voix un peu à cause de la télévision la
télévision est une formidable machine à
éclairer mais la télévision est aussi
une machine à oublier quand on ne passe
plus à la télévision les autres passent
et tout ça fait que on est balayé et
c'est très difficile je crois de se dire
que l'on restera dans la postérité avec
toute cette masse d'informations d'image
d'événements qui roule sur le monde
c'était facile autant de flaubert ou
bourillon ne fera auprès des émissions
romain soir t
moi je vous ferai les émissions hommage
vous promet peut-être du mal on dira qu
16 dollars voilà vous êtes très fort
c'est que vous avez j'arrive à faire ce
bouquin là sans parler de vous en fait
oui alors vous savez gérer un malin il
ya une différence à gleason politique
c'est que eux disent toujours nous
sommes transparents oui moi je ne suis
pas pense pas du tout non mais à une
époque où votre ami jean marie rouart
raconte ses coucheries à montparnasse g
c'est terrible d'ailleurs oui alors ça
vous a pas donné un petit peu l'idée
vous d'aller un peu plus loin dans les
confidences alors roy dit tout moi je
n'ai pas grand chose non mais d'ailleurs
quand on relit les articles quand on
relit les articles ont été écrits sur
vous on s'aperçoit vous êtes toujours
méfier terriblement des journalistes
parce que vous laissait rien paraître
vous devez vous méfier des biographes
parce qu'une fois que vous serez plus là
les mecs qui vont fouiller dans vos
packs mais sa voix est bien c'est que tu
devais me faire re ah ouais l'idée qu'il
puisse y voir graphique mois et qu'on
cherche dans ma vie sa mévente
j'aime à me quoi chaque pas trop de moi
près la même
même si vous vous détruisez toutes les
lettres par exemple de femme c'est une
supposition que vous avez reçus pour
demander à ces femmes à qui vous en avez
écrit détruire autour de lui tout en
volutes ou mail à vous faites un hommage
sur arte et c'est tout riendeau
d'accord alors je bats ya des choses
qu'on sait pas mais par exemple si je
suis très curieuse genre est ce que par
exemple surya est ce que vous avez déjà
fait l'amour en costume d'académicien
par exemple non non jamais elles sont
fort même
mais même j'aurais pu par exemple le
faire sans habits d'un camille siens
mais un big crunch
non non est-ce que vous avez déjà
pratiqué des jeux érotiques avec l'épée
jean alesi est bon secours on va vous
expliquer sans arrêt que vous êtes au
bout du chemin gens nous on veut pas le
croire bien entendu on pense que ce
livre n'est destiné qu'à vous faire
aimer encore plus si c'est possible
puis qui aura après alors encore plein
d'autres c'était bien c'était vraiment
bien c'était vraiment super bien mais
quand même pour conjurer le sort on va
passer à votre oraison funèbre est
patent voici dieu de paix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allahou akbar
genre genre jeunot nous ont quittés
jeannot janon le réac un jalon la
thrombine comme on l'appelait étouffée
dans son sommeil par un glock terreux
c'est une sommité
mais c'est aussi un père un grand père
et même un arrière-grand-père 1 que nous
pleurons ce soir consiste à dieu j'ai un
mot étouffé par tong l'air à présent je
vais demander à gilbert elle est le
frère de journaux de devenir nous parler
de ces familles de ce frère donc gilbert
je vais te demander de venir percuter un
peu vieux lui aussi alors je me mets
aussi monsieur le curé mais bien est
dehors alors dans le micro les jobards
alors alors alors alors alors alors mon
gâteau
je n'ai jamais su te dire que je t'aime
mais aujourd'hui j'ai envie tout qui
arriverait pauthe
j'ai envie de te tenir début oui jeannot
je t'aime tu vois tu aurais dû mourir
plus tôt pour me l'entendre dire alors
vers 80 ans bombail 80 piges la tête et
le turc impact est à péter commun on est
avec tout ce que tu t'es foutu dans la
gueule tout au long de taille se profile
pas non plus c'était quand même la
moindre des choses
enfin alors donc non je termine donc
mise alors donc seigneur jésus marie
promet de n'être pas georges est en soin
de lui et surtout garde le prétoire pas
de blaye n'en veut plus pas de
résurrection
merci gilbert bercy l'eau où il est
jeune on a entendu les messages d'amour
que tu lui envoies j'ai à mon amour à
vous quand il tend par des nos coeurs
comme ça tu nous causent bien des
emmerdements
voilà une petite horizon suis [ __ ] que
j'ai fait pour janot 1 jean d'ormesson
voilà petit exercice
[Applaudissements]
merci bien nommé merci dont vous aurez
tout ce soir pas le prendre comme ça ces
gens vous avez bien lu la ligue et à
manger bien entendu nous sommes jaloux
oui c'est avec nous dieudonné parce qu
après l'oraison funèbre
il ya jugement dernier un interview
jugement dernier
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson
1 tu utiliser ta notoriété pour séduire
je crois que me suis servi des femmes
pour être connu ouais et ensuite je me
suis servi de ce que j'étais connu pour
avoir des femmes à jean d'ormesson
as-tu consommé des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas pas suffisamment
[Applaudissements]
jean d'ormesson as-tu pêcher en
accomplissant l'acte d'amour sans
volonté de procréer c'est ce qu'il faut
dire la vérité
bah au jugement dernier oui d'accord
jean d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la bouffe
as tu envie d'une jeune cousine vraiment
dégueulasse oui secret défense jean
d'ormesson
as-tu plus durant son existence à la
communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu
oui comment je me rappelle que saisi
racontant d'entre nous est entre nous
non moi je ne voulais pas ruiner d'un
coup tout le capital de sympathie que je
me suis attirée je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup
plus à les homosexuels qui ont été les
amis très chers à moi que j'ai beaucoup
aimé et quelquefois j'ai été obligé de
courir un peu dans la salle de bain et
moto2 ou autant de la cuisine ça s'est
arrêté là
jean d'ormesson as tu regardé tf1 le
samedi soir il m'est même arrivé de
regarder thalassa
il est arrivé le tout regarder jean
d'ormesson
as tu déjà eu envie de te suicider
je me suis toujours arrêtée sur cette
pente parce que je pense que le suicide
ratée est une chose très ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr je ne cesse de mentir j'en
appelle à l'assistance
l'enfer ou le paradis parfait
on savait tous maintenant c'est plus la
bête de mourrir de l'horizon sud est le
jugement dernier
si on vous avait demandé vous auriez
choisi le danseur ou le paradis vous
connaissez la réponse célèbre pour pour
le climat oui je préfère le paradis mais
pour la compagnie me l'enfer merci genre
alors dieu mais le divorce de patrick
c'est un triomphe parce que votre
théâtre la main d'or mais plus assez
grand nom n'arrivait plus extraordinaire
c'est génial mais on pouvait plus donc
là l'olympia c'est pareil c'était
complet olympia bourg et donc il ya un
autre lympia quant au 17 février
mais je veux dire allez-y jean alesi
allez-y tout ce qui regarde et allez-y
c'est extraordinaire c'est le meilleur
spectacle que j'ai vu depuis jamel
debbouze jo vraiment c'est génial non
seulement je vais y aller
ouais mais encore way la prochaine fois
que dieudonné se présente à la
présidence de la république
je demande à être sûr directeur de
campagne
tôt ou tard pour rentrer en
communication avec les femmes veut dire
attends mais la femme c'est l'avenir
baird
aujourd'hui un mec qui sait parler aux
femmes c'est un atout professionnel
extraordinaire mais la femme est un
marché énorme c'est des milliards
je suis persuadé mais quand les femmes
et son arrivée sur terre 1re au départ
en 1914
je verse était certainement dans un but
de pacifistes certainement qui manquait
quelque chose sur leur planète qui n
avait pas des matières premières de la
laine du chocolat et du persil des
conneries des fois le serpent garder ça
c'est moderne c'est un sas et d'enfants
sa saison
le petit bonnet de bain qui va avec
[Applaudissements]
à moi broadway je suis trop fort son
sillage pourquoi
et tu fais pas autrement dans la vie par
déjeuner avec moi des études à d'accord
fera d'abord complètement 1 et donc et
dans quelle d'entrer dans le castrat
enfin de géorgie 6 ans et 3 gosses
[ __ ] si tu veux la mettre aux
majorettes cette gauche 1 qu'elle aille
se faire violer dans les caves à 13 ans
à part je ne sais qui mais vas-y puisque
c'est ça que tu veux pour ta gauche
[Applaudissements]
salle à ottawa c'est un personnage
odilon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai nommé le 17 mai
à l'olympia les messieurs merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
pour la lna à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant à la sphère dit
falco et j'accueille guillaume sérina
[Musique]
bonsoir les hommes série n'a donc
monseigneur di falco est il oui ou non
un prêtre pédophile première plainte
pour viol déposée l'an dernier par un
ancien élève a été classée sans suite
pour cause de prescription
mais aujourd'hui la sphère rebondit avec
la découverte d'une nouvelle victime
présumée révélée par vous guillaume
saurina dans votre livre la sphère dit
falco l'église en question
ces deux éditions ramsay golias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors lundi après demain nouvel épisode
judiciaire dans la sphère di falco pour
statuer en fait sur la possibilité ou
non de passer au delà de la prescription
parce que en matière de viol faut bien
le préciser il ya une prescription de
dix ans après la majorité de la victime
est ce que les juges lundi peuvent
revenir là dessus les juges peuvent
revenir là dessus ne le feront peut-être
vraisemblablement pas pour ne pas
contredire la première décision
mais effectivement il ya eu un recours
déposé par marc la première victime
auprès du doyen des juges d'instruction
qui lui a demandé un refus d'informer et
donc effectivement la chambre
d'accusation maintenant va se prononcer
après demain on va savoir si un juge
d'instruction sera nommé pour simplifier
ou si la sphère s'arrêtera là si la
sphère s'arrête comme vous dites en fait
les avocats de paul et de marques qui
sont les les pseudos des victimes ont
décidé d'aller jusqu'à la cour
européenne
oui absolument il y aura
vraisemblablement un recours d'abord en
cassation et ensuite auprès de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et là
ça deviendra intéressant parce que les
lois n'étant pas les mêmes en europe
nous verrons bien ce que dirait la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme alors
l' affaire a été révélée par le magazine
l'express c'est vous ensuite vous avez
enquêté pendant un an
guillaume saurina sur cette affaire
est-ce que vous avez rencontré
monseigneur di falco
non non il a refusé effectivement les
différentes demandes d'interview que
j'ai pu lui faire alors nous avons
invité évidemment ici monseigneur di
falco qui n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
ici ce soir il a déclaré sur europe 1
mon nom a été jeté en pâture discréditer
le but est atteint
je suis saly est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya un complot contre monseigneur
di falco alors c'est effectivement la
thèse
un petit peu vécu les que je trouve
personnellement qui est mise en avant
par monseigneur di falco et ses
défenseurs
ça semble un petit peu facile l'histoire
de marque et de paul le prouve
des dégâts ont eu lieu psychologiquement
sur eux leurs différents
psychothérapeute peuvent aujourd'hui le
dire
ils l'ont dit devant la brigade des
mineurs qui a enquêté qui a fait une
enquête préliminaire pendant quatre mois
et demi
cette brigade a elle même entendu
monseigneur di falco
publiquement il avait dit je ne connais
pas marx était un enfant dans la cour
d'école comme tous les autres c'est
parce qu'il a dit aux enquêteurs il a
reconnu être devenu très proche de la
famille et c'est alors la thèse du
complot
c'est un petit peu facile c'est le seul
argument qu'il qu'il met en avant si je
puis dire et ça ressemble un peu à du
désespoir
alors non seulement mon chien di falco
mais cet argument effectivement en avant
mais enfin il dit que des
invraisemblances notamment dans votre
livre
il dit par exemple qu'il n'a pas quitté
le séminaire français de rome pour des
raisons demeurent mais parce qu'ils
étaient appelés à paris pour devenir
évêque auxiliaire de paris alors par
monseigneur lustiger précisément
monseigneur di falco fait un raccourci
un je ne dis pas qu'il ya eu qu'il est
parti pour cela j'ai effectivement dans
mon enquête rencontré un jeune prêtre
qui est aujourd'hui dans une paroisse à
paris qui aurait eu des problèmes de
moeurs chose qu'il a tout à fait ni et
bien entendu je l'expliquent précisément
je ne dis pas donc que c'est à cette
période qu'il a quitté pour les dates je
m'en suis tenu à son cv officiel
alors peut-être qu'il n'est pas d'accord
avec ses propres data lui alors les
faits guillaume saurina parlant marque
la première victime présumée à 10 ans le
bien sûr donc c'était en quelle année
les faits présumés remontent aux années
72 75 me c'est à dire que selon marc les
viols se sont perpétrés pendant presque
quatre ans selon lui plusieurs fois par
mois bien à l'époque marc été élève dans
un collège à 3 actions à saint thomas
d'aquin à paris et monseigneur di falco
à l'époque tu peux manger dans 10 salles
qu il était un prêtre il était
professeur lui il était directeur de
l'école primaire saint thomas d'aquin
c'était dans la même rue et le domicile
personnel
seigneur di falco était atone en quel
âge avait marre qu'à l'époque marc avait
12 ans et avait 15 ans quand les faits
se seraient arrêtés et manger lundi
falco avec l âge
monseigneur di falco avait une petite
trentaine d'années il est arrivé à paris
puisqu'il est d'origine marseillaise il
est arrivé à paris en 68 pour prendre
justement des responsabilités à saint
thomas d'aquin
alors que s'est-il passé et bien ce que
marc raconte précisément avec pudeur
mais aussi avec précision ce sont
effectivement le déroulement de ces
différents viol en tout cas elle raconte
sa première fois de façon précise et
surtout il raconte c'est en ça que c'est
très intéressant
comment il s'est fait approcher comment
cette relation a débuté et comment cette
relation a pu perdurer plus de trois ans
comment monseigneur di falco qui n'était
pas m'enseigner effectivement l'époque
comment le père di falco s'était
rapproché de lui lui avait fait des
cadeaux l'emmener en sortie cela seul
dans paris le faisait dormir chez lui
devenu ami avec la maman de marque
il a même effectivement assisté officié
durant les obsèques du père de marc
absolument là on est un an après la fin
des faits relatés par marc est ce que
c'est pour sa part dont mais que marc a
mis 13 ans pour en parler parce qu'il
avait vu le père di falco aux obsèques
de son père ce que dit marx et que ça
lui a volé la mort de son père d'une
certaine façon ils avaient déjà le deuil
à faire de son viol
marc à 12 ans évidemment on n'avait
jamais eu de relations sexuelles
auparavant c'est la première fois que ça
arrivait quelque chose d'extrêmement
troublant la mort de son père officier
par le père dit falco son agresseur
présumé
ouais ya de quoi être avoir des
problèmes psychologiques très lourd à
part le témoignage de marc il n'y a
aucune preuve de ce que vous avancez
il n'y a aucune preuve puisqu'il n'y a
aucun témoin
donc au départ on pourrait dire pour
simplifier c'est une affaire de parole
contre parole
maintenant ce que la brigade des mineurs
de paris a fait comme travail pendant
quatre mois et demi ce que moi j'ai plus
de mon côté trouvé comme éléments de
preuves puisque effectivement ça remonte
à maintenant près de 30 ans c'est une
sorte de contexte refait et qui prouve
effectivement en tout cas les liens très
forts que les deux personnes marquées le
père di falco avait cessé parce que
c'est terrible pour moi je suis
catholique
c'est vrai que j'ai besoin à faire cette
interview c'est vrai que pour nous c'est
entendre des choses comme ça c'est une
question très grave très très con
question très grave et je ne peux pas
laisser passer ça sans dire quelque
chose je ne connais pas mon seigneur
falco si il ya eu des événements comme
celle que vous dites c'est un drame pour
cet enfant je ne sais pas qui est marque
mais c'est un drame pour mark
il ya aussi des cas où il ya des enfants
qui ont attaqué ou qui ont dénoncé leurs
instituteurs quelquefois c'était vrai
quelquefois ce n'était pas vrai alors je
pense au drame de marc
je pense aussi aux drames de monseigneur
di falco
si par hasard ce n'était pas vrai voilà
un homme évidemment déshonoré jeté aux
chiens tout comme disait le président
mitterrand
tout à fait tout accusé a droit à la
présomption d'innocence donc monseigneur
di falco à mes yeux jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il est innocent tout à fait
puisqu'il n'y a personne pour
représenter
il faut bien que la vois quelqu'un
s'élève qui est la mienne en disant je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas et il ya
sûrement des recherches à faire en tout
cas cet homme est encore eu à 100 est de
toute façon c'est un drame soit pour
l'enfant soit pour lui et c'est une
affreuse il soir je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous bien entendu il faut
faire attention aux abus de dénonciation
dans ces affaires extrêmement pénible et
délicate
nous sommes en présence de quelqu'un qui
a parlé en tout cas qui a porté plainte
à l'âge de 40 ans c'est donc quelqu'un
qui a j'allais dire mature et mais qui
dans son silence dans sa souffrance n'a
pas su comment faire il en a parlé à sa
mère dix ans après il a engagé des
psychothérapies onze ans après douze ans
après et c'est après dix ans de
psychothérapie en voyant carole bouquet
à la télévision qui est porte parole de
l'association la voix de l'enfant qui
exhortait les victimes à sortir leur
silence qu'il a réussi si vous voulez à
prendre contact avec la voix de l'enfant
qui était le point de départ de deux des
poursuites judiciaires dont nous sommes
en présence aujourd'hui leurs médecins
ont témoigné devant devant la brigade
on sait qu'ils ont été violés qui l'ont
été à toucher ça il n'y a pas de doute
là dessus a pressé par qui marque apple
amène de témoignages extrêmement
troublant parce que précis et
circonstanciés sur la personne de jean
michel di falco genre liège c'est
quelque chose qui rit joue à lire un mot
je vous employez je suis là vraiment je
suis ému et je suis bouleversée pour
l'un et pour l'autre et on si cet enfant
a raison c'est un drame épouvantable
si cet enfant invente cet enfant qui est
maintenant 40 ans c'est un drame
épouvantable
et même si l'un raison c'est un drame
pour l'autre et même si l'autre a raison
c'est un drame peu premier et je pense
dans mon livre je parle du mal et bien
nous l'avons là et cette souffrance me
déchire vraiment c'est ce que les deux
victimes disent problème effectivement
c'est qu'il ya donc une deuxième victime
qui s'appelle paul a alors là ça s'est
passé en quelle année
ces quelques années plus tard on est à
la fin des années 70 c'est pas à saint
thomas d'aquin habituel alors les deux
hommes
monseigneur di falco apple se sont
rencontrés dans le contexte de
saint-thomas meeple ensuite a été élève
de bossuet et c'est à bosse week
voilà et ce paul donc après 13 ans
danalyse son psychothérapeute constate
qu'il ya aucune amélioration de son état
et le psychothérapeute pense que seule
la justice peut apaiser sa et donc il le
laisse porter plainte et c'est donc la
deuxième plainte enregistrée dans cette
affaire voilà pour continuer la
discussion j'appelle jean chevais
[Musique]
jean chevais bonsoir des avocats vous
défendez les enfants victimes de
maltraitance et vous êtes l'avocat
principal d'une association qui
s'appelle l'enfant bleu voilà et vous
publié aux éditions numéro un un livre
qui s'appelle l'innocence profané
[Musique]
alors la sphère dit falco coupable ou
innocent toute façon peu importe je
dirai pas ce que parce que la justice
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ne peut pas faire
son travail de ces prescriptions
deuxièmement vous pensez également que
c'est de mauvais aussi pour les victimes
pour les présumées victimes parce que
après le battage médiatique a commencé
avec l'express qui va continuer qui va
s'amplifier
de toute façon eu ça ne fait que
qu'accroître leur peine et leur mal ça
va pas les c'est pas ça qui va les
guérir ils auront forcément un sentiment
de frustration ses deux garçons
ouais parce qu'on ne pourra jamais faire
la preuve que leur récit est vrai alors
vous vous interrogez aussi jean chevais
sur le le peu de soutien apporté à
monseigneur di falco par par l'église
catholique quand même tout à fait le
parquet l'a lâchée en pâture dans les
médias alors qu'il pouvait pas être
poursuivi et l'église n'a pas levé le
petit doigt
personne ne vient les soutenir alors
qu'on sait et c'est ce que je dénonce
est-ce que ce que j'ai vécu dans
certains procès deux prêtres pédophiles
qui est reconnaissait les faits qu'ils
avaient des dizaines de victimes
et là on soutenait ces curés pour dire
non non il faut absolument rien dire 1
la loi du silence et celle ailleurs dans
ses danseuses dans cette optique que
monseigneur piquant que j'ai poursuivi
et qui a été condamné lui pour non
dénonciation alors pourquoi on klur on a
vu jean-paul de prendre une vraie
position officielle et dire que les
faire le ménage que ça suffisait y at il
plus de pédophiles parce que votre livre
commence d'ailleurs par exemple qu'elle
soit pédophilie dans l'église
dans l'église catholique qu ailleurs que
dans la société que dans les autres
églises
c'est à mon avis pas tout à fait le
problème
les faits de pédophilie les plus
courants se passe dans le cercle
familial car là c'est que le fait que
les prêtres ne soit pas mariés parce
qu'on a
la question qui vient à l'esprit c'est
disons qu'à se marier mais vous pensez
non selon moi c'est pas tout à fait le
même débat le ciel célibat des prêtres
est le problème de la pédophilie l'inde
n'est pas lié forcément à l'autre la
plupart des pédophiles aujourd'hui on le
sait il ya un certain nombre de
statistiques sont des gens de marié qui
ont des enfants qui ont des relations
sexuelles hétéro ou homo tout à fait
normal en revanche on sait qu'un
pédophile même inconsciemment va trouver
un métier où il va être en contact avec
des enfants
instituteur éducateurs prêtre ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il ya plus de prêtres
pédophiles que dans da que dans d'autres
professions
les prêtres pédophiles qui ont eu des
ennuis
il y en a une soixantaine c'est énorme
il faut pas non plus en france il faut
pas non plus jeter l'opprobre sur toute
l'église
et moi je n'ai pas écrit ce livre c'est
l'église face à la pédophilie c'est pas
un livre contre l'église c'est un livre
contre ceux qui salissent l'église c'est
pour leur faire prendre conscience
l'église la hiérarchie doit faire son
mea culpa
elle doit avoir à mon sens une attitude
claire stressé face aux états unis 1
oui mais le pape a convoqué les évêques
des etats-unis
pourquoi n'at-il pas convoquer les
évêques de france ou d'europe 1 et puis
il y a dans la position du vatican
quelque chose qui n'est pas très clair
parce que on vient dire la conférence
des effets que en novembre 2001 a dit il
faut il faut plus soutenir il faut
dénoncer etc
mais en même temps au vatican on a fait
passer une consigne en latin qui n'a pas
été donnée à la presse pour dire quand
vous découvrez un prêtre pédophile vous
le fait savoir au vatican on va
l'enlever
on va le juger devant un tribunal
ecclésiastique
mais à ce moment là on va déplacer le
prêtre très bien mais et la souffrance
des enfants il faut les aider et les
procès médiatique il ya eu ont aidé les
enfants à parler
merci
merci merci guillaume merci jean chevais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voulais lieu je crois que d'abord
j'ai été un petit peu solennel tout à
l'heure pardonnez moi mais il ya des
moments où il faut quand même j'ai pensé
à l'histoire du bagagistes d'orly
bah ouais je pense que vous l'avez eue
ici chez vous elle a juste avant vous ce
soir ils étaient là ce soir juste avant
moi c'est ça a été un drame épouvantable
alors encore une fois moi je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas non plus pour omar raddad
jeu
je ne sais pas il me semblait qu'il y
avait au moins un doute
et quand il y a un doute le doute
profite à l'accusé et emma je vais vous
laisser rentrer en suède donc de trouver
votre côté vous en faites pas vous avez
les mains sans aller une autre va entrer
merci dites moi
dites moi vous allez revoir tira est en
deçà lors à la rochelle ont besoin pour
taxi 4
oui merci
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et maintenant mon bien qu'on voit si
julie andrieu
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
la liaison est ce que je veux dire un
mot oui je perds ma oui je retrouve
julie avant la fin c'est tout c'est une
demi surprise pour moi il ne savait pas
que j'y serai là je sois avoue que
l'essai jury comme on la connaît il ya
longtemps que je l'admiré que je laime
et
je suis enchanté d'avoir joué ici à côté
moi ce soir si marié 1
je suis comme ça je me sens en famille
avec lui s'en protéger voilà où il est
battu gamme aussi je suis heureux de
pouvoir pas tellement pour vos recettes
de cuisine parce que moi je suis pas
trop grasse trop nomme le pass 1 jour
vous serez jolie et je rêvais de
rencontrer
alors j'ai bien connu votre mère bras
c'est normal c'était l'idole des gens de
mon âge à nicole courcel donc vous vous
êtes donc là c'est normal vous vous
connaissez la mère moi je connais
[Musique]
alors j'ai 28 ans puis vous êtes à la
tête julie d'un joli petit business
c'est une sacrée femme d'affaires vous
avez trouvé une idée un positionnement
marketing c'est la jolie fille qui
s'occupe de la cuisine et ça marche
on y aura une soirée concurrence était
méritée donc quelques garçons mais dans
les filles ya pas tellement réalité vous
donc vous êtes journaliste culinaire et
critique gastronomique alors c'est une
cumulards là j'ai fait le compte de tout
ce que vous faites vous chaud mais pas
dans la presse écrite il ya elle est le
figaro oui à la tam le figaro marie
claire aussi marie claire aussi pardon
après 10 ou publier des coûts et mieux
alors si vous publiez des livres les
vaux bien sûr mais vous participez aussi
au guide le b donc voilà c'est comme ça
à la radio rmc info
non j'ai arrêté parce que je voyais à la
télé il ya toujours t20 en rediffusion
et je ne travaille bien et est en
rediffusion et cuisine tv cuisine tv
et puis en plus de ça vous est
consultante pour des marques que je ne
citerai pas ici pour pas encore énervé
le csa enfin des marques très très
importante
julie ne répondait à aucune pression
sans consulter
jusqu'à la savane
ce qui reste une place pour l'amour dans
tout ça julie andrieu je me le demande
on a fait une place aux et depuis peu de
temps à essayer d'arriver à caser à un
homme c'est quand même la priorité oui
ça a été votre priorité est d'entendre
des choses comme ça oui c'est sur cette
très jolie vous devez pas manquer de
deux soupirants vous êtes très mince est
ce que c'est parce que votre cuisine et
pas très bonne
non c'est parce que parce que voilà ce
que répondait qu'il aille se faire
[ __ ]
j'ai lu et ça c'est lamentable mais
c'est lamentable
c'est lamentable mais c'est lamentable
voilà merci pierre alors quelle est la
recette que vous réussissez le mieux non
mais j'en fais une différente chaque
jour parce que c'est un peu de mon
métier je suis essayé je vais j'ai dîné
chez vous un soir avec jean bien sûr en
tout bien tout honneur on y va tous les
deux on va dîner chez vous vous nous
recevez qu'est ce que vous nous faites
pour nous épater
pour vous épater je vous ferai un plat
bien traditionnels en plein de terroir
que je réussirai j'espère presque aussi
bien que maïté de vous faire un plat
world food où vous ferait un très bon
bourguignon
je frémis ajouté plusieurs heures
amoureusement lourd pour le soir on
gagne on ne sait pas lourd du tout le
bourguignon n'est pas lourd c'est une
sauce aux ventes des nuits de gras
l'alcool s'évapore
si vous me lancer sur le domaine du
bourguignon non les plats aux fins et
pas les plats lourd c'est moins alors qu
une blanquette évidemment à d'accord oui
crème obligé mais si vous êtes venus
comment cette idée de faire de la
cuisine est d'abord il n'y a pas eu
d'idées c'est une envie surtout a eu une
passion qui reste actuel et puis en fait
ça mais en tout cas c'était pas c'était
pas familiale parce que comme vous
l'avez dit ma maman n'est pas dans les
fourneaux est ce que c'est votre père en
plus en sortant du théâtre elle bouffe
et une heure du matin le lendemain je
regardais à la télé à 13 heures voilà
donc non moi c'était surgelés sa plate
pas de cuire pendant 20 minutes avec on
sort en boîte c'est peut-être par action
parce que c'est plutôt pas pour ça et
puis sinon nombre pourquoi est ce qu'on
a envie tout d'un coup de se mettre au
piano ou au tennis
j'aimais ça j'ai découvert que ça me
plaisait qui avait un plaisir
convivialité de sensualité et puis je me
suis passionné pour ça et je suis la
tête dedans quand tout va bien tout va
bien un problème c'est ce mec là moi
j'étais pas au courant ici au courant ça
vers sérieux quoi la cellule ouais t'es
dues à ces choses là il ya des moments
comme ça dans la vie enfin bon enfin
qu'est ce que vous voulez j'étais bien
ouais c'était bien en tous les cas comme
vous êtes la reine des recettes
je vais vous faire une interview
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'évite vocale si forte
pouvez vous me donner la recette du
gloubiboulga est le groupe eelv au gabon
mais tout dans la casserole on laisse
mijoter très très longtemps qui on
attend que ça colle ouais si si c'est ça
mais on met quoi dans la casserole
alors de la confiture de fraises des
bananes écrasées des saucisses de
toulouse cru mais tiède et de la
moutarde
je vais essayer de nous faire ça quand
on ira chez vous avec jean alors en
faire plus simple quelle est la recette
du sandwich au jambon sans lecture
gendron
deux tranches de jambon et au milieu une
tranche de pain voilà très bien en faire
on va faire plus utile maintenant la
recette pour séduire un mec
justement on essayait de pas en avoir
bon pas facile hein ne pas verser dans
le jeu et dans la comédie mais peut-être
de loi est de limiter les trucs au
maximum
là je suis tombé sur un qui aime ça donc
c'est bien tant mieux
j'ai pu bien votre recette pour virer un
mec en général au bout d'un moment ils
ont pris tellement de poids qui
finissent par s'en aller de même après
une dizaine de kilos en quelques années
chaque soir votre recette pour dire non
le premier soir d'abord il m'arrive de
ne pas dire non première soit le premier
soir à rabat sa médaille d'argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez à quel point cette émission
est con il suffit de dire il m'arrive de
ne pas dire dans le premier soir pour
que toute la salle soit en délire
d'autres j'imagine quand même non notre
recette pour refuser imaginez que vous
refusiez pour des soins puis pas un jean
et des la lc pas refusé c'est à dire non
c'est tout juriste je voyais même pas me
rappeler dernière question la recette
pour avoir votre numéro de portable mais
c'est pas moins de la donner pour une
fois la recette là ouais maintenant faut
faire preuve d'un peu d'imagination
ouais comment on peut le trouver senna
en cuisine et je vous lis on m'a
tellement fait souffrir là que je quand
je vais le mettre aux enchères match
numéro deux
[Musique]
et maintenant avec mon méchant jamais
content
non échange mais si christophe alévêque
[Applaudissements]
ok
des savants soir alors qu'il se fait les
mecs vous toute façon tous vous énerve
à commencer par les ogm et jeudi dernier
vous avez été avec toute une bande de
gens ce que vous avez fait arraché des
plants de colza c'est ça non eh ben on a
en a on est ans et mis les pieds dans la
boue et on nous avons donc arraché des
plants de
maïs je pense enfin
ouais quand génique pour montrer que
nous étions nous étions totalement
contre ouais et pour soutenir également
josé bové a est d'accord et beaucoup de
gens c'était une manif pipeau là ah bah
oui oui puis on a mis nos trucs en
plastique pour pas se cacher non c'était
très alors ce qui vous énerve aussi la
mondialisation
pourquoi ça vous énerve ça m'énerve
parce que c'est quelque chose d'un peu
forcée d'un peu obligatoire d'un peu à
la mondialisation surtout la
mondialisation économique parce que
sinon on en fait toujours ça doit faire
du bien
non parce que j'ai un truc qui me gratte
dans le règne depuis une heure
heureusement que ça me gratte que
l'oreille ce qui vous énerve aussi
l'éducation des enfants à l'éducation 10
ans ce qui m'énerve surtout c'est la
théorie
c'est à dire que quand on n'a pas
d'enfant on est les meilleurs parents du
monde et une fois qu'on en a mais c'est
les deux j'en ai deux enfants et une
femme dont l'arrivée trois raisons de
voir l'argent ça vous énerve ça m'énerve
oui mais ce qui m'énerve c'est le
principe de l'argent c'est à dire que
quand on en a pas on dit on vient
souvent deviens fou et quand on en a
très souvent devient con donc oui la
vieillesse ça vous énerve
ce qui m'énerve surtout dans la
vieillesse et les jeunes militaires
c'est nous dire qu'on a un peu tendance
est là on revient c'est un peu la
société moderne la société occidentale
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où un
vieux enfin ils ont dit plus vieux on
dit donc personnes âgées maintenant on
dit plus vieux con mais personnes âgées
de droite je n'avais pas la louper ça et
c'est ce qu'ont fait les vieux qui ne
sont plus productifs maintenant donc
hélas on l'est on les met dans les coins
comme ça on l'aimé dernier dans les
centres de retraite dans des académies
françaises
voilà on l'aimé enfin c'est pas tout le
temps ouais ça m'excite aussi des fois
c'est non mais c'est vrai que j'en parle
beaucoup dans le dans le spectacle je
passe je ne veux pas c'est un peu pour
un misogyne ce que ne je ne suis pas du
tout je ne suis pas misogyne je suis
marié donc alors on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble
magnéto serge
à
car google n'ont pas peur je me peu
fatigué en ce moment parce qu'avec ma
femme on a un passé la nuit aux urgences
que le plus petit a testé la
signification du mot show jeu jusque là
si encore les bordels était resté ouvert
mais ils ont été remplacés par les psys
c'est pour moi c'est moi hazard a vo
alors pour être vraiment sûr de mon
manque total de culture à tous les
niveaux bonjou vers le dictionnaire au
hasard je tombais sur la lettre e aux
mairies sont de grands jarrah en vo me
vois mal par exemple jouer aux boules
réussir un carreau par fait gagner la
partie 13 12 et lever les bras au ciel
en disant voilà ce qui s'appelle une
antenne et chili finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on dit ça vous a tout vécu
plekanec son tour en train de poser des
questions toujours tout le temps il pose
tout le temps des questions
ils savent rien
coupet moi je suis pour faire manger les
enfants avant et mènent à leur faisant
perdre une pantoufle et parce qu'ils
perdent toujours une pente au scoop est
fier et nous casse les couilles de son
gros ce thème
voilà christophe alévêque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà christophe alévêque alors c'est
vrai que vous n'êtes jamais content
toujours de mauvaise humeur dit toujours
non ben c'est à dire que le voit la
colère me nourrit un peu drôle sinon à
part ça dans la vie je suis quelqu'un de
plutôt assez sympathique un romantique
vous faire une interview de nom pourrait
répondre un genre si vous voulez passer
des questions qui s'applique aussi à
vous aussi à vous le prénom que vous
n'auriez pas voulu porter adolphe
adolphe mois joseph levis que vous
n'auriez pas voulu avoir aucun le tous
le fantasme que vous n'aimeriez pas
avoir
vouloir absolument être connu ouais
ouais faut pas votre cas vous la femme
avec qui vous n'auriez pas aimé coucher
stevie du loft
l'un des deux hommes à ses clients des
grosses conneries quoi aussi avec qui je
n'aurais pas aimé couché c'est celle que
je préfère
oui c'est salir ma mère à la perversion
sexuelle que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir
christophe alévêque c'est moi j'ai une
petite pervers surface il sait rien
j'aime bien peloter les seins malaisie
c'est parce qu'elle mangeait le problème
c'est que j'aime bien la télé ça mais
pendant très longtemps
ah oui à dire scène pendant des heures
de la rencontre que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire andreas baader
parce que je pense que je l'aurais
peut-être suivi a le physique que vous
n'auriez pas aimé avoir le mien le mien
pourquoi parce que vous avez une tête de
personnage des années 30
ben oui mais le prochain problème c'est
qu'on est en 2003
[Applaudissements]
l'accueil que vous n'auriez pas aimé
accomplir sauvé la vie du président des
états unis c'est tout faire et que son
bretzel la qualité que vous aimeriez pas
avoir la correction la blague que vous
n'auriez pas aimé raconter c'est elle
est assez horrible et courtes donc c'est
c'est un peuple c'est un petit fils qui
va voir son papy c'est qu'ils valoir il
dit aux papilles
c'est à boom en ce moment papy fait je
suis réglé comme du papier à musique
à cette heure je fais pipi à 7h30 je
fais caca puis à 8 heures je me lève
c'est la bad que vous n'auriez pas aimé
raconter et épargne une version encore
plus courte et plus horrible ouais si
vous voulez évidemment
non pas qu'ils sont d'accord brothers de
cadres et c est donc là ses petits-fils
toujours un minibar sa mamie la sam
amidon qu'il arrive chez la famille il
ouvre la porte de chez la mamie je fais
royaume a mis ça pue la mort ici
mamie
[Musique]
quel
bien
et maintenant oubliée qui dit laver
il
voici robert ménard
[Musique]
robert ménard bonsoir vous connaissez
julie andrieu jean d'ormesson qui se
fait lévesque
alors robert ménard vous êtes
contestataires depuis vos 15 ans à
l'époque en 68 vous êtes en troisième et
vous réussissez un premier exploit qui
est de faire fermer votre lycée ça a été
votre premier grand fait d'armes dans la
foulée vous devenez un anarchiste
tendance situationniste et en 73 au
moment du coup d'état de pinochet
vous reprenez goût encore plus aux
activités militantes et vous devenez
trotskiste à ce moment là à la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire la fameuse
lcr alors vous allez à la fac est votre
première victoire à la fac c'est contre
une usine de produits chimiques et vous
tirer tout ça une certitude c'est
finalement on peut arriver à ses fins
sans recourir obligatoirement à la
violence simplement faisant beaucoup de
bruit
c'est ça à peu près oui je crois que
quelques personnes décidées à un moment
donné on peut faire des choses on peut
générer des choses les minorités
agissantes voilà alors cela vous
conduira au journalisme puis à reporter
sans frontières le reporter sans
frontières vous en êtes le fondateur
c'est une cause que nous défendons ici
assez régulièrement
on peut dire celle amnesty international
de la presse d'une certaine façon oui
écouter aujourd'hui à plus d'une
centaine de journalistes emprisonnés
notre boulot c'est de les sortir de là
vous disiez jean d'ormesson que c'était
pour la liberté dans la moitié des pays
du monde aujourd'hui a pas de liberté si
vous pensez différemment du pouvoir vous
allez en prison
nous on essaye de sortir ces gens là qui
dont le seul crime le seul délit en gros
c'est de mal penser d'ailleurs pas
penser comme les autorités les zones
problématiques et encore des zones à
dans le monde surtout par exemple les
pays qui sont encore communiste
il ya beaucoup de journalistes
emprisonnés là-bas corée du nord
au laos est absolument les
les pays où il est plus dangereux de
faire ce métier c'est ce que vous direz
c'est ce qui reste de pays communiste
les pays du monde du monde musulman et
puis un certain nombre de vieilles
traditionnel dictature je pense je sais
pas par exemple à la bière magnin où il
ya les journalistes emprisonnés depuis
plus de quinze ans par exemple
alors vous publiez avec emmanuelle
duverger qui est qui est juriste et qui
est responsable de la justice
internationale à la ligue des droits de
l'homme
un livre qui s'appelle la censure des
bien pensants c'est chez albin michel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le pitch du livre en parlais tout
à l'heure avec jean ii de pitch le pic
du livre c'est trop de bien pensants ce
fait du mal à la pensée oui ce qu'on a
voulu dire avec les manuels c'est assez
simple c'est évidemment la situation en
france est la reine avant est ce que
vous venez d'écrire
on n'est pas dans un pays où on risque
d'aller en prison comme ça parce qu'on
pense différemment aujourd'hui de
monsieur de monsieur chirac hier de
françois mitterrand c'est pas ça le
problème
en revanche à d'autres risques c'est que
dans la loi dans les habitudes dans les
pensées il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui sont de fait interdite en
particulier tout ce qui est choquant
c'est à dire pour les meilleures raisons
du monde on défend les droits de l'homme
et tourne interdit un certain nombre
d'expressions et on a essayé de faire la
liste de ces expressions de ses points
de vue qui sont inacceptables aux yeux
de certains alors il vous dit que pays
de voltaire et de rousseau vous vous
demandez s'il est encore possible de
penser librement
compte tenu de tous ces interdits
certains légaux d'autres pas alors avant
de continuer cette discussion
je voudrais accueillir arno klarsfeld
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
arno klarsfeld arnaud on vous présente
plus est le fils de serge et béate
klarsfeld avocat international
parallèlement vous a vu sur canal + dans
une émission qui s'appelait citoyens
qu'à romancier sportif
tombeur on peut le dire aussi et
secrétaire général de la licra à paris
très longtemps il ya très longtemps
il ya très longtemps alors je passe vous
connaissez le livre de ménard la censure
des bien pensants on va commencer avec
la vente d'objets antisémites sur
internet sur yahoo
donc des insignes nazis des dagueys 16
des bonbonnes de zyklon b sont
accessibles en france et il ya eu une
plainte de la licra et de l'union des
étudiants juifs de france pour que ça
soit interdite en france la vente de ces
objets qui est autorisé aux états unis
centre de yahoo c'était interdit sous
prétexte c'est compréhensible que c'est
une offense à la mémoire collective
voilà donc la justice a demandé un
filtrage mais les avocats de yahoo en
californie ont fait appel et un juge
américain a déclaré que la loi française
ne veut pas s'appliquer car le siège de
yahoo justement comme je le dis et aux
usa voilà ici à la loi qui dit voilà ce
que vous pouvez faire vous pouvez pas
faire aux etats unis c'est pas la loi
qui décide de sa la constitution
peut-être parce qu'on n'est pas dans les
mêmes pays
c'est un pays libéral où on dit toutes
les opinions peuvent s'exprimer et on
fait confiance aux gens au caractère
adultes des gens pour décider entre ce
qui est raisonnable ce qui est absurde
ce qui peut être choquant ce qui peut
être bouleversant pour certains et
puisqu'il n'est pas évidemment
évidemment que c'est monstrueux d'aller
acheter un certain nombre d'objets du
troisième reich
évidemment que les gens qui font ça ils
sont évidemment des traqués dans leur
tête mais je ne crois pas on ne crois
pas qu'avec l'interdiction fera avancer
les choses c'est ça le pari le pari
c'est dire il y en a marre de
systématiquement faire appel à l'état
on peut faire confiance aux gens on peut
parier si les gens d idée stupide
on essaie de les convaincre qu'ils ont
des idées stupides nous allons enfin sur
yahoo par exemple ils vendent pas de
drogue ils vendent pas de livres
pédophiles sur yahoo
donc en france et en amérique ont donc
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer que dès
que des bonbonnes de zyklon b c'est
quand même quelque chose le zyklon b il
faut dire à nos amis jeunes
téléspectateurs c'était quand même le
gaz qu'on mettait dans les chambres à
gaz donc quand il ya des gens qui
achètent ça est ce que finalement ça
peut être considéré comme un ouvrage
pédophiles ou comme de la drogue et être
interdite sur yahoo une fois pour toutes
non je crois que c'est pas la même chose
je crois que c'est pas la même chose
pourquoi c'est choquant c'est chaud tant
pour ce que ça représente
vendre du zyklon b c'est bien ça fait du
saf est due cette pause delà du chagrin
et de la peine à ceux qui ont vécu qui
ont perdu leurs parents et peut-être on
vendra du zyklon b dans 50 ans dans 60
ans quand quand ceux qui auront perdu
leurs parents
et bien ne seront plus là et quand le la
tragédie de la shoah sera sorti des des
coeurs pour devenir l'histoire jusqu'à
là cela cause du tort à ceux qui ont
souffert et qui souffre encore de
de ça mais est ce que vous vous
mobilisez quant à moscou on en vend
aujourd'hui les signes de l'armée rouge
le communisme dans le monde ses 80
millions de morts on sait bien que pour
lutter contre le communisme pour
recruter et je suis d'accord avec vous
contre le retour de toutes ces
monstruosités
il faut lutter mais sûrement pas par
l'interdiction on passe au cas des
révisionnistes auquel un chapitre de
votre livre est consacré robert ménard
donc le plus connu des révisionnistes et
faurisson robert faurisson
alors eux ils nient l'existence des
chambres à gaz dans les camps
d'extermination nazis
alors vous vous dites ils ont raison ils
sont l'objet ces gens là d'une véritable
chasse aux sorcières
ils sont victimes de la police de la
pensée ils sont victime d'un
détournement du droit à cause de la loi
gayssot
c'est à dire que des gens qui affirment
des choses que l'on s'est contredite par
tout ce que l'on sait sur la solution
finale
finalement vous dites il arrive à faire
passer grâce à la loi gayssot pour des
victimes de l'intolérance et vous dit
cette loi gayssot
c'est une ânerie c'est une loi inique je
précise tout de suite que je ne partage
en rien évidemment le point de vue des
révisionnistes ce qu'il dit ce sont des
absurdités et je leur dis si simple en
ce que nous disons c'est deux choses
d'une part ce sont des absurdités
mais en ayant mis sur pied une noix
exprès pour interdire ils sont moins
d'une dizaine
on leur a fait la plus belle publicité
qu'on pouvait leur faire d'une part
d'autre part ça reste des idées
monstrueuse choquant blessantes vous
avez raison mais des idées d idée fausse
parce que attendait ses 5 966 et
complexes ont pas dit ce matériau est ce
qu'on peut parler à demi nue alors c'est
tout ce que vous voulez ça parce que je
peux parler vous me laissez parler ce ne
sont pas des ces fossés sont des ordures
antisémite qui savent très bien que les
choses ont eu lieu qui savent très bien
que les juifs ont été exterminés et qui
pour faire passer leur haine antisémite
et bien disent les juifs n'ont jamais
été tués finalement quand vous fait
insulter vous allez droit devant
dommages et intérêts quand vous fait
injurier vous avez le droit de demander
des dommages et intérêts quand voit on
des voix le vote pris vie privée vous
avez le droit de demander des dommages
et intérêts quand vous au quand on dit
que quelqu'un était que coupable de
faits de collaboration alors que ça a
été amnistié il a le droit de demander
de dommages et intérêts et ont dit un
tout un peuple
vous volez 6 millions de morts n'ont
jamais existé et ceux qui ont perdu
leurs parents qui sont traité d'escroc
parce qu'ils ont touché des réparations
ils ont aucun droit
c'est hier vous vous parler en termes
intellectuels ou en termes comme ça sans
prendre en considération la souffrance
des gens quand les derniers survivants
ceux qui auront perdu leurs parents
eh bien ceux là sont morts et bien à ce
moment là la loi est bien le sort a
abrogé parce qu'elle n'aura plus de
raison d'être
mais maintenant si on dit vous en faites
vous êtes un sale escroc juif qui a
touché des réparations alors que vous
alors que l'on a une seconde alors que
votre alors que votre mère est mort
c'est une insulte alors je vois pas
pourquoi ce que ceux qui on dévoile la
vie privée le droit de juger des
réparations et ceux d'autres ont dit
vous êtes un escroc et vos parents sont
pas morts n'ont aucun droit
et bien cette loi sera abrogée voilà fil
du temps quant à l'or aujourd'hui quand
on dit par exemple si quelqu'un dit la
saint-barthélemy n'ai jamais eu lieu
bon bah poursuivi mais qui souffre
aujourd'hui qui a perdu ses parents de
lors de la saint barthélemy personne
quelqu'un perdu son arrière arrière
arrière arrière arrière grand père donc
les souffrances les plus vivaces
il n'y a plus de gens qu'on comprend
qu'on promet du ballon a tonné pour vous
robert ménard toutes les idées même les
plus odieuses doivent pouvoir s'exprimer
premier point et deuxième point aucune
idée évidemment de pouvoir échapper à la
critique à la dérision et à la
caricature voilà donc vous êtes partisan
d'un absolu de la liberté
mais est ce que pour la liberté comme
pour le reste est ce que l'absolu n'est
pas inatteignable et très dangereux n'en
ont dit deux choses on dit d'une part il
ya deux limites à la liberté
d'expression assez les appels à la
violence si je dis il faut tuer monsieur
d'ormesson
évidemment c'est plus de l'ordre de
l'idée messieurs dames c'est une
tentative de meurtre une association ou
pas vous parce que vous achèterez à côté
de moi la dette
11e point celle insultes personnelles
vous avez le droit de vous défendre
à partir de là on doit pouvoir débat je
me méfie on se méfiait qu'emmanuel de
quelque chose de simple c'est ce qu'ils
veulent penser à notre place on vit on
sort d'un siècle
on sentait ce siècle où il ya des gens
pas y jouer pas une insulte via touche à
une jambe qui file à zulte de je vais
penser à votre place
c'est pas cher c'est pas une insulte de
dire à des gens qui ont perdu leur père
ou leur peur leur père en fait vous ne
les verrez perdu personne
vous êtes un escroc résultat si c'est
une insulte alors ce doit être non
pourquoi non bonjour si c'est oui si je
vous dis vous est une ordure la paix on
dit pas vous pourrez même amour dans ce
cas là vous le dis pourquoi pas briller
pour vous le dites à l'ensemble d'une
part et du catégories populaires excusez
moi mais ce que dit arno klasen c'est
finalement dire les chambres à gaz
il y avait des camps de concentration
mais ce n'était pas des camps
d'extermination ski le discours des des
révisionnistes absolue ce qui dit
finalement c'est une insulte aux gens
qui sont morts
je vous prends un autre exemple il ya eu
je le disais à peu près 80 millions de
morts du fait des communistes pendant
des années il ya un certain nombre de
gens ici des grands responsables
politiques qui ont ni et le goulag max
était une insulte aux victimes du goulag
est ce qu'un d'entre vous c'est dit on
va poursuivre ce marché on va poursuivre
les communistes à l'époque parce que il
est ici sauce est attentatoire à la
halle à la mémoire des victimes
évidemment pas les gens qui disent il
n'y a pas eu d'extermination des juifs
comme on le sait maintenant
évidemment c'est insultant évidemment il
faut le combattre
mais évidemment pas devant les prétoires
évidemment pas devant les pressions bas
c'est ce qu'on va pas devant les
prétoires
c'est ce combat par les travaux
universités xion quand giscard d'estaing
disait y avait cent mille juifs qui ont
été déportés de france mon père a montré
qu'ils avaient 76 mille juifs qui ont
été parfaits de france et non pas 100
milles
quand raul hilberg dix le nombre de
juifs qui ont été exterminés plutôt de
l'ordre de 5 millions et 6 millions
personne ne pense à l'accuser de rêver
isme bon genre vous pensez qu'il faut
abolir la loi gayssot nom alors je pense
que dans l'idéal évidemment je partage
absolument votre opinion dans l'idéal
c'est la liberté totale
mais c'est vrai que en pratique nous
avons tous une espèce de dette en europe
à l'égard de la shoah favorable je
prends un autre exemple parce que dans
dieu merci dans ce livre on parle pas
que des régions 10 à 20 ans non non on
parle d'autres gens sur le racisme
le racing je ne suis pas non plus
raciste est-ce que la meilleure façon de
combattre le racing est tellement de ces
accords les dix ans il ya tellement il
ya tellement de cause dans le monde
super ya des enfants qui meurent de faim
il reste que 6000 revenir aux quelques
milliers tigre géant on tue des gens ici
à droite et à gauche tout ce que vous
venez dire c'est oui il faut que les
révisionnistes où il faut que les
racistes puisse s'exprimer
je m'en balance moi raciste c'est à ce
prix mais ces panneaux ont nagé pas
vraiment besoin de vos leçons pour
défendre la liberté ailleurs et pas
seulement dans des salons s'il vous
plaît la civil selon l'adq là selon la
deuxième chose que vous quels sont vos
au fait quels sont vos au fait qu'est ce
que c'est c'est la maison quel salon
c'est moi oui de saint-louis non
exactement ça vous prend de faire casser
la gueule
moi j'ai reçu des bombes moi j'étais ici
moi j'ai été là quels sont vos faits
vous on vous attend vous attend vous
attend jour le jour pour défendre la
liberté après tout ça c'est nouveau fait
ça quels sont vos risques personnels que
vous avez pris attendez-moi général pas
ici mais risqué mais n'a pas ou alors il
y en a pas venant de vous faites quoi
rigoler ce que je me titillait ça c'est
ce qui s'appelle normalement mais de la
crétinerie à plus haut point non et
c'est sain c'est le sens de la tolérance
ça c'est vraiment quelle tolérance
robert encore un mot en eau klarsfeld un
plaidoyer pour la tolérance maintenant
je te les rangs mais j'suis pas
tolérants avec les racines ni raciste ni
négation de tout ce que vous savez c'est
celle des racistes etc
nice vous explique ça je vous dire non
on défend à longueur de temps je défends
à longueur de temps des gens qui dans
leur pays sont en prison sont en prison
pour leurs idées ça ça existe bien alors
tant qu on vous tient à nos classes fel
de quand guy sorman kit anti sioniste et
là il est contre l'existence de l'état
juif
quand il dit israël est un accident
historique et ça rappelle un petit peu
ce que colombani rapporté dans son livre
il disait qu un jour colombani il dînait
à l'elysée alors il dit pas qui a dit ça
mais qu' on a parlé au sujet d'israël à
l'elysée ce soir-là de parenthèse
historique et lui sorman ils parlent
d'accidents historique qui dit qu'
israël voilà c'est arrivé en 48 puis que
ça cesse rac ce serait super pour
l'éternité
vous réagissez comme ans quand vous
voyez un c pour ca qu arafat à papa pas
voulu de faire la paix avec avec barak
c'est parce qu'ils croient que encore qu
israël peut peut disparaître et que
beaucoup d'européens le croire encore
encore encore et que si finalement les
rafales se dit il vaut mieux ne peut ne
pas rentrer dans l'histoire comme celui
qui a fait la paix avec avec les
israéliens et
si l'état croisés a disparu et bien
israël peut disparaître quelqu'un qui se
place dans une perspective historique
n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu d'israël
pendant pendant
ddd siècle pendant 2000 ans est bien ici
israël peut disparaître c'est ce que et
peut-être pas mal de diplomate européen
ou au quai d'orsay ont à peu près la
même approche que l'ancien porte parole
du quai d'orsay qui était ambassadeur de
france à londres qui a dit qu israël
était un petit pays en mer de qui on est
emmerdé le monde et ils disent
finalement va avec sans état d'israël le
monde serait plus simple plus vous sera
plus facile mais enfin les si les juifs
n'ai pas d'état et bien il est juif se
ferait persécutés aussi ailleurs dans le
monde et israël remparts à
l'antisémitisme aussi dans le monde et
ce n'est pas israël sans doute que les
négationnistes sans doute que les juifs
s'organiserait pour éliminer tout
simplement les négationnistes parce
qu'après que après que six millions de
juifs étaient des tués est bien les
ennemis du peuple juif doivent être
créés doivent être combattus c'est la
leçon car tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus
non non non non recevoir de la flotte
on se méfie maintenant ce qui est
insupportable
m klarsfeld s'est pas du tout ce que
vous dites moi je partage pas votre
point de vue sur tout mais quand vous
dites qu arafat et un sinistre
personnage je suis absolument d'accord
on voit ce qu'il fait à son propre
peuple c'est un régime corrompu
népotique il n'a jamais un mot pour
condamner un vrai mot pour condamner les
attentes les attentats kamikazes tout ça
vous avez raison mais une fois qu'on a
dit ça on a le droit aussi
m klarsfeld de critiquer monsieur sharon
sans être pour autant taxés ni d'
antisémite ni de quelqu'un contre les
palestiens et moi je ne jette pas de
l'eau sur notre humeur
d merci robert ménard merci à l'état
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
voici benoît delépine et jules edouard
moustic mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
benoît delépine bonsoir jules edouard
moustic bonsoir dont vous faites partie
tous les deux des rescapés de canal+ a
voté mais leur expliquer les règles du
jeu au départ donc toi tu lances un
verre d'eau sur mana suis venu justement
à un homme de pelle mais mais gaudet
sont vides benoît qui lance un verre
d'eau sur nous nous sommes les hommes de
la réconciliation
voilà donc je disais vous faisiez partie
des rescapés de canal+ votre émission
sept jours au groland et même passer en
prime time le samedi de 20h30 à 20h55
bravo comment ça se fait on était un nom
était repassé aux oubliettes et en fait
on a une grande de lutte avec un certain
jean-marie messier mots ouais on voulait
d'ailleurs porté plainte au commissariat
du 15e pour vol démission oui mais on
n'a pas fait parce qu'on s'est dégonflé
ça fait dix ans que ça dure quand même
c'est justement pour ça on se demande
après la deuxième année finalement donné
un but de plus ouais mais d'ailleurs je
vous dit tout de même commencer parce
qu'on a un petit peu suivi de le débat
en coulisses ouais et moi je voulais
remercier robert ménard selon tant que
reporter grâce à un reporter sans
frontières moi j'ai eu un petit pépin
qui m'est arrivé dans ma vie
professionnelle il ya quatre ans
effectivement lors de la sphère de la
bête du gévaudan
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez un
petit peu de ce qui s'était passé mais
j'étais resté en planque avec le une
brebis pendant une semaine
j'étais accusé de pédophilie mais
totalement injustement et reporter sans
frontières était là pour me soutenir
grâce à arnaud n'est requis c'est une
réconciliation et de pluie depuis cette
époque bénie d'ailleurs grâce un robert
et arnaud le mouton devient droit pour
le journaliste qui manque c'est un droit
de l'homme un droit du journaliste
humain alors le volant dedans qu'est
votre le pays en fait d'où vous venez
c'est une précis poté le président est
autour élu pour sept ans il est le seul
à avoir le droit de vote auto auto
proclamés élus tous proclamé avis
millet parce que en fait il est très
beau oui c'est salengro scénographique
oui très graphique on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble que s'articulent heures tu
aimes ça hein
je suis désolé je fais pas un sur la
guerre civile en afrique mais les ogm la
misère en forme moi j'ai pas le temps tu
peux maquignons monjournal deux minutes
sega rejetteront choix concours vivre en
ville bonsoir l'actualité c'est vous qui
la vivent et c'est nous qui en vivent
ont tout de suite un scoop mondial notre
reporter michael kael et quelque part
dans une grotte afghane avec oussama ben
laden michael c'est à vous et oui
jules-edouard je suis son côté de lui
l'ennemi public mondial numéro un
oussama ben laden alors oussama as tu
peur de mourir
ça me dit que non que le sacrifice fait
partie intégrante de la djihad attendait
michael nous on veut le voir allumé une
torche ou un briquet je sais pas moi
vous plaisantez je les dois retourner la
moindre source de chaleur lumière
provoquerait i do i call attaque d'un
drone américain nous nous devons de
rester dans l'obscurité la plus totale
ah d'accord alors on ça ma deuxième
question c'est honteux michael c'est
honteux
ouais mon loulou bas vous êtes au bureau
nous bureau un bon ça va à temps il ya
eu assez de journalistes qui sont fait
trop et la peau là bas à la peine d'en
rajouter un peu de respect pour cette
profession djavann ok bah demandé à
oussama si je peux pas avoir une
barrette pour demain
le café aussi nous l'avait rappelé sur
canal c'est existe en vhs et dvd ça
s'appelle grosse landsat le best-of
[Musique]
merci
m
roland que 5
en dvd vhs et le samedi à 20h30 sur
canal à 20h55 bénin monsieur robert je
vous laisser filer merci sécher avait
mettre votre costume dans le sèche-linge
en tous les cas à bientôt robert et
sachez qu'on continue ici à soutenir
reporter sans frontières je le sais
merci quoi là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'invité suivant on va vous faire
plaisir en ormesson c'est quelqu'un que
vous aimez beaucoup dont vous respecter
les heures joey starr et là c'est pas
joey starr puisque lors de sa dernière
visite jean d'ormesson avait choisi
d'écouter les meilleures chansons de
joey starr
ce soir lancé lionel richie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
line dessous
oui
[Musique]
we are very happy en vérifiant toulouse
air lines and the square et demi en
blanc mais le public avec moi
je pense je pense que ça mérite un
triomphe romain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai
alors là lionel richie est ce que j'ai
compris un truc je vais me lancer dans
la chanson
7 est-ce que vous êtes bien en france
est ce que vous êtes heureux quand vous
êtes en france
je suis très bien ici en france très
très bien
qu'est ce que vous préférez en france
oui c'est vrai les fils ça compte aussi
disons que dans mes années de jeunesse
avec les commodores il a tout à fait
raison c'était les français les gens la
cuisine tout ça c'était maintenant
j'aime toujours les filles des français
toujours là dans la cuisine française
quelque choses n'ont pas beaucoup changé
mais disons que le public a toujours été
très loyal très fine et alors c'est vrai
là lionel qu'à l'époque des commodores
au début des commodores avant le succès
vous allez chanter sur la scène du
byblos à saint tropez c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire
imaginez-vous 700 y avait c'était une
époque il y avait mick jagger qui venait
d'épouser bien carney si je ne m'abuse
il y avait de grosses pierres qui
étaient enfin c'était la comédie
musicale du siècle et puis tout le monde
a sa propre recette pour faire la fête
alors fait le spectacle était
littéralement dans la salle
voilà ça c'était les débuts de lionel
richie après il ya eu ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne l'avais
[Musique]
risa
m
nous
cya
you may
m
d
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
cela
c'est un super
marteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où il va
je
[Musique]
quand il
et enfin
[Musique]
il saura
obama
mais
[Musique]
ça
c
c'est mon ouïe
[Musique]
à
on croyait suffit
[Musique]
moi
l'axé l'homme
m
pas de vision
christelle
soit
[Musique]
voilà la yamaha xj6 son morceau qui ces
morceaux voix jean d'ormesson
m
batiscan
et justesse
jean d'ormesson applaudi mais malgré
tout je pense que julie andrieu est en
train de se faire salma draguer par là
j'ai vu j'ai vu comment ça se passait
entre j'ouvre la bouche pour le dire non
seulement julie m'a lâché pour lui mais
encore de temps en temps je me demande
s'il n'est pas plus populaire que moi je
suis assez ému que line richie soit
présent que je vais en face de moi quand
même parce que c'est you say me pour moi
c'est une chanson culte et une belle
chanson d'amour puisque c'est pendant
ces ihu semic j'ai connu mon premier
fils paul king of kings
voilà je sais mars en sont extraits d'un
best-of intitulé encore sur lequel il ya
deux inédits mesdames les yeux
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà light 600 millions d'albums vendus
est facile et qui sont du fait tout près
de 100 millions d'albums vendus 30
millions avec les commodores et 70
millions quand il a été tout seuls comme
quoi c'est bien fait de partir alors
vingtaine énorme vingtaine j'avais été
couvert de récompenses et surtout en
1984 lors des jeux olympiques de los
angeles
il va chanter all night langue devant
2,3 milliards de téléspectateurs dans
deux mois qu'est ce qu'il a gagné
[Rires]
lineage qui vous étaient en 1949 dans
l'alabama dans une petite ville qui
s'appelle de ski dgi et vous êtes revenu
maintenant vous habitez de nouveau dans
la dans cette ville la saison que j'ai
toujours une maison là-bas même si
j'habite en fait sa maison avec ma
famille bonjour le jour j'ai toujours
une maison sur le campus universitaire
université là bas alors votre
adolescence a été marquée par deux
grands hommes martin luther king et
malcolm x qui ont été d'ailleurs
assassiné tous les deux alors à l'époque
vous venez d'entrer à l'université de
tests qui fit 166 et quand vous entendez
parler d'un mouvement qui se forme parmi
les jeunes noirs et dont l'objectif est
de répondre à la violence des blancs par
la violence des black eyes et pas de
discussion possible
ça s'appelle les black panther bien
entendu et et vous en faites partie
pourquoi en 1967 c'est à dire un an
après avez vous quitté les black
panthers
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est que j'étais un petit peu
idéaliste lorsqu'on l'a 19 ans on se dit
que l'on peut vraiment faire une
différence que l'on peut faire changer
le monde et je me suis rendu compte que
les black panthers voulait trouver le
poids tout en restant dans la
ségrégation tout en restant isolés du
reste du monde mais moi au contraire je
cherche t
gracia avec le reste de la société alors
je me suis rendu compte que à cette
époque j'avais un choix soit je vais
rejoignez les commodores soit je restais
à des coups bas contre j'ai choisi les
commodores parce que la nuit et puisque
vous avez refusé le communautarisme
alors l'autre influence que vous avez
subi c'est celle du pasteur martin
luther king et à un moment vous vous
avez eu envie de devenir prêtre vous
voulez voulait devenir prêtre
c'est tout à fait vrai voilà mais au
moment d'entrer au séminaire ligne
richie a rencontré les commodores alors
là avec les commodores cela la galère
commence un combien de temps avez vous
mis avec les commodores pour faire votre
premier tube c'est quand ils étaient
ensemble depuis six ans avant avant de
faire nôtre c'était je pense que je vais
j'avais déjà terminé ma première année
d'université puis après ça on a donc
qu'on a quitté l'école c'est bien qu'on
a commencé à faire la musique à temps
plein 15
ouais c'est ça a mis énormément de temps
alors l'autre personne qui a eu beaucoup
d'influencé aussi dans votre villa
lionel richie et michael jackson d'abord
parce que vous êtes passé en première
partie des jackson five à tes skis
dgi.un et ça vous a lancé parce que dans
la salle ce soir là c'est berry gordy le
patron de la tamla motown qui étaient
dans la salle
et quand il vous a vu en première partie
des jackson five il vous a signé tout de
suite voilà c'était le président élu
l'autre moment où michael jackson a été
très important aussi dans votre vie
c'est quand vous veniez d'être évincé
d'une certaine façon par les commodores
et michael jackson vous a dit continuer
tout seul c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
planté mes frangins depuis je suis une
énorme star il fait de faire off the
wall et donc vous avez fait pareil et
vous avez vendu deux fois plus d'albums
tout seule voix alors avec michael
jackson vous avez composé tous les deux
cette magnifique chanson
ah non c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
entendu je suis d'accord mais c'est
quand même une belle chanson qui
s'appelle we are the world
ça s'est passé comment vous étiez vous
quand vous l'avez écrit de cette chanson
j'étais à los angeles
je j'ai reçu un appel de harry belafonte
qui m'a dit voilà on a tous égaux qui
voudraient faire quelque chose pour
sauver la famine en afrique et je
cherche des des chanteurs des artistes
noirs allaient faire quelque chose donc
j'ai contacté puis san jose et et on a
onze j'allais écrire une chanson avec
stevie wonder
j'appelle study on n'arrivait pas à se
coordonner alors michael jackson était
juste à côté on va essayer de travailler
avec lui on s'est retrouvé au studio
spiller on a décidé qu'on allait qu'il y
aurait quatre personnes steve mcqueen 6
et moi et alors on était en studio et et
c'est là que la rumeur s'est répandue
campagne ont écrit cette chanson est
bien tous les artistes nous ont appelés
pour nous demander s'il pouvait faire
partie de ce groupe
alors il ya des quelque 45 artistes qui
se sont engagés alain côté et puis on
s'est dit ah ben voilà on va faire ça la
veille des music awards à los angeles
et c'est là que bongo j'étais
l'animateur de l'émission et le
spectacle est à 2 10 heures du soir à
une heure du matin le lendemain on a
donc enregistré et on a fait d'ailleurs
la vidéo devant la zone à la ml ritchie
avec we are the world on est loin de
george w bush parce que lui c'est plutôt
i'm the world
alors est ce que tu as fait aujourd'hui
vous faites partie des américains qui
veulent aller faire la guerre en irak ou
plutôt des américains qui pensent que
c'est une énorme que je crois que si on
fait la guerre c'est parce que la
politique a échoué parce que la
diplomatie a échoué et je crois que
vraiment c'est le hameau le tout dernier
recours c'est d'aller envoyer des gens à
la guerre parce que ça fait ça veut dire
que le dialogue est épuisé et il ya
quand même plein de gens intelligents
sur terre moyens quand même établir un
dialogue c'est pas possible on peut
dépenser des milliards et des milliards
de dollars pour acheter des machines de
guerre et faire
hereafter et à travers mais on peut
faire beaucoup plus de choses avec cet
argent il ya une famine qui règne un peu
partout dans le monde il ya des
problèmes d'éducation il ya plein de
choses qu'on pourrait faire avec cet
argent je pense que la toute dernière
chose à faire c'est de dépenser cet
argent pour faire la guerre c'est
construire des bombes et que sais-je
essayons plutôt de nous servir de la
diplomatie pour sauver les choses
[Applaudissements]
cela dit cela dit d'autre part si
vraiment la diplomatie échoue bon mais
il faut faire ce qu'il faut faire
autrement dit là maintenant nous sommes
arrivés au stade j'ai l'impression que
nous avons atteint le point de
non-retour disons que la diplomatie doit
être quand même le facteur primordial ce
qui m'inquiète j'ai l'impression que
nous sommes allés probablement allé trop
loin dans tous les sens je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs où cela va aboutir ce que
vous croyez pas qu'il y avait il
faudrait désormais d'urgence des états
unis quelquefois oui c'est un peu ce que
je sens disons qu'il ya des moments où
je le dis ce serait quand même bien de
pas pousser le bouchon aussi loin qu'on
le fait disons que là je me rappelle ce
que nous disait mon père lorsqu'il me
conseillait sur leur mariage
ça s'applique également dans ce cas là
il ya des ja du moment où il faut
arrêter de discuter il faut quelquefois
écouter on apprend beaucoup plus de
choses en écoutant qu'en parlant
[Applaudissements]
c
j'accueille maintenant jérôme savary
[Musique]
comment ça va vous n'avez pas votre six
gars là non non non non non j'avais un
mail de bill clinton qui est pour vous
c'était quel type d'humidificateurs
utilisez vous le même que lui sauf que
moi c'est la bouche à dakar vous arrivez
jérôme savary de l'opéra comique sur ce
qui est arrivé à cette heure là donc où
il y à là toujours belle et la toute
petite bête qui est une création de vous
sur une musique de gérard daguerre avec
arielle dombasle fred avec lonbois
carlos pavlidis il est là car le
spécialiste du mans si carlos 9 et 10
[Musique]
non
alors extraordinaire carlotta be nice
voilà c'est le hérisson c'est la bête on
se demande d'ailleurs pourquoi dans le
film de cocteau la bête qui est
magnifique se transformant en jean
marais qui est passible si vieux que ça
moi je pense qu'elle aurait dû aimer la
bête tout simplement il était formidable
jean-marie ville avait tété plus belle
alors voilà carlito que nous sommes bons
gars d'auditoire james pour la peau
pékin
voilà donc carlos pavlidis donc alors
alors carlos et mon garde du corps
ouais et j'ai expliqué à l'ats une aile
richie que ce qu'il faut garder en
général quand on a un corps peut être
éventuellement mon cas mais surtout il
est mignon la haine et de richie c'est
la partie d'en bas et carlitos occupe
donc du bas et tout à l'heure s'il ya
des questions pourtant sur le dessous de
la ceinture c'est carletto qui répondent
à coeur jérôme donc le pitch de votre
spectacle c'est un peu portnawak as un
conte de fées raconté à l'envers de
travers des enfants moi j'aime pas les
contes de fées je suis un je dois le
dire un peu allergique à walt disney et
je n'aime pas les gens en je n'aime pas
les gens en peluche qui agite les bras
et j'aime pas que ces gens-là se
prétendent artistes alors qu'on voit
même pas leur regard et je ne comprends
pas pourquoi il faut que la bête dans
tout ça il ya eu 142 mais belle et la
bête pourquoi la bête doit elle se
transformer en prince charmant
par exemple nous avons tous ont dit tout
en nous avons tous une bête qui
sommeille en nous oui est ce pas jean
d'ormesson
nous sommes tous oui et je voyais tout à
l'heure ce qui ce qui transforme la bête
en prince charmant
c'est le regard de l'amour est là c'est
l'histoire d'un homme qui essaie de
séduire une jeune veuve arielle dombasle
délice magnifique je dois le dylan
elle est belle elle est gentille elle
est professionnelle il faut arrêter de
considérer qu'arielle dombasle est une
poupée barbie sous prétexte qu'elle est
jolie
on veut absolument se convaincre qu'elle
est bête c'est pas vrai elle est
intelligente elle est drôle elle est
extraordinairement sexy ayant en elle
une bête qui sommeille et alors car les
taux le nain se déguisant hérisson
essaye de séduire la belle qui a perdu
c'est une jeune veuve
qui a perdu son mari peau est tombé d'un
pommier et il réussit à lille à
l'émouvoir voilà il faut dans cette
pièce est une véritable révélation elle
chante elle danse et j'en crois le dise
oui ça fait un tabac
il m'a bourré tous les soirs y compris
moi d'ailleurs non mais je crois qu'elle
va démontrer avec ce spectacle c'est une
grande actrice populaire on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble juanito serge
s'arrêter
c'est un combat
côté
mais donner un long baiser sur la bouche
et amélie précis je ne croirai un beau
prince ne le quittez pas ne cliquez pas
sur les longues votre main l'ombre de
votre chien de ma visite est pas f
[Musique]
il était sur son
non
[Musique]
pas mal
et cela
c'était à l'aube un comique
[Musique]
alors jérôme savary on va parler un
petit peu de vous allez-y vous avez 60
ans absolu vous êtes né en 1942 à
bouinan crs en argentine
votre père dans les années 30 était un
pacifiste un écolo un personnage un peu
à la radio un peu à la jean giono
intellectuel parisien qui avait épousé
une héritière américaine et qui voulais
être écrivain mais qui n'a jamais réussi
à publier son premier roman et qui est
mort avant assez jeune à 50 ans c'est
souvent le cas les artistes ouais il ya
beaucoup d'écrivains qui n'ont jamais
terminé leur premier alors quand la
guerre arrive comme il est pacifiste
votre père il part avec votre mère en
argentine fonder une communauté
pacifistes ont une espèce d'utopie comme
ça dans les années 40 journaux à a prôné
le retour à la terre bien avant les les
hippies un moyen était hippie je suis
maintenant baba cool mais ce retour à la
terre chez jeauneau c'était quelque
chose de très fort et ce refus de ce
refus de la guerre aussi refus de la
guerre donc cette utopie a fini par
foire et surtout ma mère a découvert
dans la communauté de mon père il y
avait toutes ses maîtresses et le jour
où ma mère a découvert que ils se les
envoyait tout payer en plus un peu comme
raël c'est que c'était une sauf c'était
une communauté pacifistes et sincèrement
vraiment libéral ll est parti et l'a dit
à mon père je voudrais un cadeau de
divorce
fais moi un dernier enfant voilà elle
voulait une fillette à tout prix et donc
je m'appelais noémie mon nom et mon
véritable nom et je venais après le
divorce de vos parents voilà alors quand
vous étiez petit jérôme vous avez eu
deux types d' influence devant le swing
sur votre mère écouter charlie parker a
tout le temps jusqu'à 20 tonnes et la
pampa parce que votre mère refusé que
vous alliez à l'école parce qu'il
fallait saluer le drapeau
c'était l'époque d'un dictateur pour
élise qu'ils appelaient perron et mes
frères salué le drapeau en uniforme la
petite cravate et ma mère a dit je vais
sauver un mais trois filles c'est donc
là j'ai pas été à l'école jusqu'à l'âge
de 8 ans voilà des gens avec des villes
terre dans la bande pas et parce qu'elle
ne voulait pas que je sois en uniforme
je l'en remercie l est
les lao explique que vous soyez un
autodidacte totalement absolument oui
parce que par la suite j'ai raté mon
bepc
j'ai jamais dépassé la troisième je dois
dire à jean j'espère entrer un jour à
l'académie française comme vous je pense
que je le mérite
exiger à laquelle je suis ravie donc je
vais poser alors vous revenez en france
à la fin des années 40
votre père réalise qu'il a manqué une
partie de son histoire
oui parce qu'il n'a pas fait la guerre
ils étaient ni juif ni vous en avez
parlé formidablement tout à l'heure
c'était un fils à papa
sa femme avait dû du fric et quand il
est rentré ici aperçu qu'il avait raté
cette grande aventure
il s'était mis à l'abri il avait raté
cette grande aventure et c'est un peu
l'histoire de l'est d'éden avec soin
merveilleux film avec avec james dean ou
le grand frère a fait la guerre est mort
et le petit frère lui n'a pas participé
à cette aventure c'est ce qu'on a appelé
la lost generation lapointe génération
perdue puis la beat generation les bears
voilà alors votre père lui il n'a pas
fait la guerre dont il a envie de
militer et il crée avec gary davis le
mouvement des citoyens du monde où il
envoyait des cartes de d'identité de
citoyens du monde à des gens des
déracinés et je dois dire si c'était un
petit bureau place de la contrescarpe et
si aujourd'hui ça existait encore tous
les sans papiers du monde
il recevait cette espèce de petit carton
où il disait voilà je suis citoyen du
monde et il ya des pays où ça marche et
voilà donc effectivement votre père
participe aux citoyens du monde et vous
pendant que votre père réaliste qu'une
guerre a eu lieu dans son pays
vous vous êtes choqué lorsque vous
arrivez au havre pas partout les vous
arrive en paquebot donc vous voyez tous
les immeubles des denrées par les
bombardements américains étant les
pommiers en fleurs est une image c'est
en 49 très très très étonnante
incroyable alors on vous envoie en
haute-loire à chambon sur lignon au
collège cévenol collège international
boilard et à 13 ans mais apparaît y
cours de solfège cours de musique chez
martenot est-ce que ce mart noël
inventeur des ondes marc absolument oui
donc les ondes martenot s'était assis
dans sa musique électronique s'est lancé
l'ancêtre du synthé ouais c'était un
instrument qu'on pouvait jouer avec un
ruban voilà c'est à dire que martenot
inventer des notes qui n'existait pas
jusque là et c'est à dire papa des deux
minutes pas des dièses l'idée bémol mais
des huitièmes 5e kints et la tige en
acier ouais tu sais quels étaient les jo
thério à l'époque à la radio française y
avait des concerts dont deux martenot
voilà ensuite fait les arts déco et vous
partez à new york parce que alors là on
retrouve comme une similitude sire que
votre père était parti en argentine par
pacifisme et vous vous partez à new york
aussi pour pas faire de gardien il faut
dire la vérité c'est pas pour pas faire
la guerre d'algérie parce qu'elle était
finie en 62 c'était la fin c'était pour
pas faire 24 mois d'une chose absolument
stupide s'appelle le service militaire
n'ont pas stupides pour le paysans
analphabètes ou pour car je les fais le
service militaire j'ai fait on a lancé
dans là dans la pente par les sept mois
dans la penderie et j'ai fait 7 mois et
90 % les soldats qui étaient dans la
pampa était très content de faire le
service parce qu'ils apprenaient à lire
ils apprenaient à écrire c'était les
gens qui venaient de la campagne mais
pour quelqu'un qui a autre chose à faire
le service militaire c'est véritablement
horrible et c'est pour ça que j'ai la
double nationalité franco argentine
alors à new york évidemment vous renouez
avec le jazz évidemment suite à tous que
votre mère vous ai fait écouter
cambrésis thelonious monk vous
rencontrer lenny bruce qui était le
premier mec à faire du stand-up pratique
c'est l'ancêtre le coluche et lenny
bruce disait toujours fuck you ouais je
te baise je vous [ __ ] en le disons que
la traduction française ce serait je
vous [ __ ] 1 et alors il y avait il y
avait un certain nombre d états du
middle west où il suffisait de dire fuck
you pour aller en taule et donc il avait
détourné c'était un coluche de l'époque
et alors ils allaient ils ne réservait
pas l'hôtel mais il allait faire à gala
à minneapolis et donc son agent lisais
je te réserve quoi comment
tu réserves pas joué en tôle sans eau et
donc il arrive bien sûr sa mise et fuck
you
les flics l'emmener en tôle et le
lendemain alors accompagné à la solution
c'était un type extraordinaire et qui
nous a beaucoup influencé 1
alors vous finissez jérôme savary pas
rentrer en france vous intégrez le monde
des argentins de paris parce que pour
les argentins
ce qui compte c'est triomphe arts à
paris un trait au phare fait on parle
voilà et donc vous devenez copain avec
copie lavelli à à bâle topor jodorowsky
mouvement mouvement panique et là on y
arrive vous fondez votre première
compagnie théâtrale qui deviendra très
rapidement d'ailleurs le grand magic
circus en garde
à quoi ça ressemble et magnéto serge
[Musique]
m
peut-être
[Musique]
le magic circus dans le giron de savary
alors c'est une communauté un armé mais
il ya débat de buru 1 c'est une espèce
de de phalanstère des hans à tabac je
préfère les gangs au sexe sincèrement à
l'idéologie
on a un but commun et là on était pauvre
comme job mais on a fait le tour du
monde
on est devenus très copains les beatles
ouais et qui sont venus nous voir très
souvent joue en angleterre deux mois par
an john lennon était mon copain et un
jour il rentre dans ma loge et il me dit
c'est incroyable ça fait trois mois
qu'on est en studio on essaie de trouver
un son pourri comme le vôtre ce que nous
on avait trois pianos des batteries
dégueulasse des vieux micros les l'un
d'eux me dis mais c'est incroyable ça
vous arrivez à trouver un sont alors que
mon lait trop propre leurs projets julie
mais c'est très simple achetez un matos
pourri vous avez vous avez trop d'argent
vous avez trop de fric et john lennon
m'a fait un chèque et on n'a pas changé
le matos a continué à être toujours
aussi produit mais on est on est devenus
amis
vous êtes allé derrière le rideau de fer
à une époque on n'y allait pas
facilement vous êtes allés jouer pour
farah diba mais la shahbanou elle
n'avait pas le droit d'aller vous voir
parce que les hommes nus sur scène et
elle est là elle a envoyé son cousin lui
raconter au palais la soirée comme dans
l'e mailing
il lui a raconté la soirée le lendemain
on a été expulsé par avion militaire on
est rentré à paris
jones a varié mon spectacle à l'opéra
comique aurait bientôt
on passe blahic 1 ce soir un blind test
spécial soldes aux platines j'appelle
mention à felip corte
[Applaudissements]
c'est vachement bien
[Musique]
oh
allez
[Musique]
didier le reste
vous connaissez le principe je veux
l'interprète c'est vraiment très facile
surtout pour vous envoyer chez un gros
avantage pour le camp auquel
j'appartiens
là c'est sûr oui d'abord remercier
vincent lagaf pour le costume
oui merci attention film dans la vie des
gens
passer de la mer machin
ce chien
fin janvier
n'essayez pas stupeflip par exemple je
comprendrais mais que vous ne
reconnaissez pas line renaud quand même
mal à percer notre enfance en voudrait
s'excuser auprès de nos camarades pour
avoir trouvé line renaud et d'avoir joey
starr à trouver michèle torr je crois
hélas été mis sur la voie jeudi celle
qui est pas morte
oui bien attention philippe david bowie
fouet
[Applaudissements]
puis eux
leur emploi
alors là écoutez j'ai mon buzzer
j'avertis j'ai dit mc solaar j'avertis
le public si vous soufflez ici à
l'attendre ici qui soufflait si le point
bas là je ne peux pas entendre ici je
vous ai déjà vu faire ce genre de trucs
ouais et quand je suis à la maison ça me
déplaît vous avez trouvé d'accord dans
nos coûts de jacques martin tout le
monde a gagné
attention attention
[Musique]
donc ça féminine à la mailing musclor
l'équipe de jean d'ormesson
l'équipe de jean d'ormesson 4.0
[Applaudissements]
qui de jérôme savary
zéro point nous nous sommes des
étrangers argentat lui les grecs vous
auriez pu passer un peu de millas
hellénique à ce gala a poli cas là
attention fille nancy sinatra
ouais
[Applaudissements]
les op
[Musique]
ce qui est encore plus génial parce que
effectivement ça il est très fort mais
en plus il est gentil parce que c'est
lui qui a amené tous ses disques c'est
incroyable c'est que je me rappelle
jamais du prénom de ma mère pour ça que
j'appelle maman ouais
et là je trouve c'est le lui bravo
bordeaux et nancy sinatra absolument une
chanson 2 qui a écrit la chanson 10 à ça
c est eux se situent pas son père mais
deux c'est pas son père je me rappelle
arcelli az oui ben on le savait philippe
[Musique]
fastoche gignac l'air
grand voyait là je vois je vois ce que
tu fais je suis à la maison je pars
pissait avant ça je sens le point noir
et était pas copain avec ma femme ou qua
non non non non non tu as connaissent
l'enjeu est là alors il pas pu défiler
les noms bon tous les gars ça fait 6
points pour l'équipe de jean d'ormesson
après les cours et les iroquois vient
s'amarrer qui perd et chili je n'aime
pas les conflits non j'aime pas les
coûts sont pas des concours y'a pas à
discuter mon condamne toujours toujours
c'est comme un la galette des rois gens
c'est toujours vous qu'il écoute je
pense que ça me glace et ça fait 2 pour
m garçons c'est bien
demain toujours gagner je trouve arnaud
classement très gentille s'il connaît
maurice-chevalier oui bah oui connaît
vraiment en dieu sait qu'il a été en
dessous pendant toute la soirée
attention philippe
[Musique]
et
me regarde
[Applaudissements]
et vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il accuse aussi la mairie sinon tu
admires ça tu admires saïd mirza
non alors mais c'est à quoi franchement
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est la première fois
que j'avais une équipe faire zéro je
suis désolé vous en foutez votre
spectacle et d'un triomphe ça va arriver
ça m'intéresse pas bien sûr je bois mon
café pmu le matin les gens qui jouent
qui grattent et où je préfère gagner
avec mon travail en vue des jeux lagon
et oui thierry jean d'ormesson se tait
en plus des sports je revois oui et ça
voudrait faire l'académie france
sohn salle ont entonné par pilote
voilà voilà
attention ça c'est dur ah ouais
c'est la bonne vitesse ça faisait deux
petits mois d'amour
m
ça c'était parfait on a fini par se
ramassent à la pelle
[Musique]
non non c'est pareil c'est du gentil en
fait c'est lynda lemay m'a interdit
nadal ont géré à fermer les écluses
entre le québec et la france je sais la
plainte eu de la musique d attention ça
c'est très dur là attention très très
dur
philippe
le jeune john
danse
[Musique]
la suisse vise aussi oui tu as profité
non non non la provision de ce que
disent que
est-ce que je peux aller
ces critiques
bon vous arrêter je vous donne le poids
mais tu vas avoir une punition la maison
elle-même a été construite autour de
c'est monsieur recul et qui avait obtenu
la concession qu'il vend pour la
première fois à une demoiselle
montmirail qui va passer de longues
années ici et cette demoiselle
montmirail avant la maison robinson les
anglais fraîchement arrivé après la
conquête de l'île c'est une punition
il avait aussi situation alors est-ce
que le point 20 à l'équipe de jean
d'ormesson
ça fait 9 0
quand ans de carrière je vous avais mis
ça c'était bien parce que total assume
aussi j'ai des cimes ils ont pas dit
stop à l'heure et sans déconner mais
taylor au clair de la lune ne viendrait
pas de toute façon vous savez une
descendance monsieur servez vous savez
qu'un gardien de saint jeantais les plus
par ici c'est chacun pour sa gueule et
thierry une règle fondamentale
l'équipe de sabri a le droit de jouer
aussi bay le savent les vexer genre elle
se dit encore en commission fin à
l'opération quand même mon garde du
corps à tanger en maintenant c'est
chacun pour sa gueule
donc là il ya plus d type de match a de
tout temps passe au super banco
jean
et
hm voilà
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enquête générale cède mon époque les
ehome à l'arrêt pour le banco gagner
paris chez moi y'a des gens qui me
disent quand ils veulent que je parle de
cinéma tous à dater quel est ce que vous
avez aimé tel ou tel film moi je dis le
dernier film que j'ai vu c'était citizen
kane avec orson welles et touray pa et à
la coupole a jeté l'épongé c'est bien
qu'après le banco il ya l'ultra banco de
toute façon à non rassure mais pourquoi
thierry parce que la vie est injuste
philippe rejet de sa vie voici le méga
banques aux filles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nystedt stocker les fiat et rs passé de
mon époque on parlait de guise
arrêtez-vous bascule après l'ultra bon
qu il y a le mega man mais pourquoi tu
es celui qui gagne une mégabanque hausse
sera le grand gagnant intégral total de
la soirée à majorque jeunes ça sera la
star a eu droit eux à triumph roma et je
pense il a plus de gobelets je pense que
j'avais de jérôme savary
jérôme écoute bien je pense que tu peux
gagner ça vous aussi
attention c'est le méga banques aux
attentions fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh la la c'est ce que c'est vrai moi
aussi c'est le magic circus à boby
lapointe
où sont passées
parcours
c'est bon
sans doute pas
je ne sais pas
voilà
[Musique]
et vous voulez en 12 ans n'a pas très
bien présente
ce prénom le prénom je vais donner le
prénom jerry ne triche pas non je fais
pas je donne le prénom des amies elles
ne soufflaient pas attention celle
d'aller les frais des graves
répercussions que donne le prénom le
prénom et jean phi
[Musique]
j'entends ces gens du passé
rentré que je vais donner un autre un dc
mais s'est fait un nom dans le civil ou
c'est non c'est son nom son nom très
connu son prénom et jean et c'est
quelqu'un qui chantait aussi ses codes
le pacha qui fait des trous ouais
oui
il est gay
constantin voilà ce week-end
t'appelles comment avec 100 comment
peux-tu connaîtra tournage jean
constantin on lui a soufflé aussi faut
vraiment ch répondre oui j'ai lu sur ta
fiche thierry je suis honnête mais
comment tu arrives à voir de la ba ba
what you want un petit fiche alors je
suis désolé de le dire mais j'ai lutté
fisher et c'est honnête
bah oui bien sûr alors enfin des jeux
quand même un triomphe romain non pas
pour toi ô gens dorment trop gendarmes
eux sont aujourd'hui
[Musique]
voilà c'était le triomphe romain de jean
d'ormesson
j'étais tout dans l'enfance l'émission
qui regardent nadir tous les samedis
soirs à l'origine sommet à rabais ras
jedir berti et basse
avec taxi toi que j'ai raccourci qualité
d'actionnaire
samy naceri frédéric diefenthal marion
cotillard bernard barsi sortie le 29
janvier et plus la bande originale de
take 6 3 jean d'ormesson
c'était bien c'était bien chez gallimard
dieudonné le triomphe de patrick le 17
février par client le divorce de patrick
le 17 février à l'olympia
guillaume saurina la terre di falco chez
l'homme c'est goliath
jean chevais l'innocent trop fan et
l'église face à la pédophilie aux
éditions numéro un julie andrieu merci
julie autour du monde le lundi à 20h30
sur cuisine
tapha l'évêque dvd vhs qui social est en
tournée dans toute la france
d'autres à delek robert ménard la
censure des bien pensants de robert
ménard emmanuelle duverger c'est chez
albin michel
et puis edouard boubat pour la liberté
de la presse
vendue au profit de reporter sans
frontières arno karsfeld merci d'avoir
été avec bio
j'adore me suis donné jean torrent élevé
dhs le best-of d'olemps ac 7 jours
hollande et le samedi à 20h30 sur canal
mais les messieurs laguiole
belgique l'album death of chapelle
encore jérôme savary merci jérôme
d'avoir été là avec le carlos bully
la belle est la toute petite bête de
jaude savary avec arielle dombasle
jusqu'au 6 avril
c'est ma musique à l'opéra côté voilà
j'ai fait tout mon enfance rendez vous
la semaine prochaine chan
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
titi est